Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So, ich war gerade noch mal schnell auf dem Klo, jetzt kann es losgehen.
Pünktlich heute hier, direkt 9 Uhr auf Start geklickt.
Abonnieren, um Drops zu verdienen.
So, so, kann man das wegmachen?
Kann man das da wegmachen?
Ne.
Das kann man bestimmt mit FFZ wegmachen, aber keine Ahnung.
Das lassen wir jetzt.
Ja, wir sind relativ früh.
Ich glaube, wir haben schon eine Weile nicht mehr wirklich um 9 angefangen.
So, jetzt 10 Leute am Start.
ich kann schon mal um betriebssystem updates machen das mache ich jetzt ist
der stream richtig gestartet ist was mit meinem hintergrund los
Ist der Hintergrund jetzt pro Desktop oder was?
Die bauen auch die sinnlosesten Features in Windows ein, oder?
Der Hintergrund ist jetzt pro Desktop anscheinend.
anscheinend.
Ja, Synaptics geht so.
Also semiheller Hintergrund.
Aber warum ist denn der Hintergrund auf dem Desktop anders?
Jetzt ist er gleich.
Das heißt, Moment, das muss ich jetzt, das ist mir noch gar nicht aufgefallen.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt noch einen dritten Desktop mache...
Hä?
Moment, da ist er jetzt gleich, wenn ich einen dritten Desktop mache.
Aber auf dem zweiten...
Okay, Windows.
Windows-Logik, ey, das muss man dann verstehen.
Mal den dritten Desktop wieder weg.
Windows-Logik.
So hell ist der Hintergrund doch gar nicht.
Dann starten wir mal meine VM.
und ich mache mal Updates.
Das schadet immer nicht.
Wird schon nicht so richtig mitgekriegt,
dass der Stream da ist, ne?
Oder gab es
so Benachrichtigungen bei euch?
Sonst ploppen in den ersten 5 Minuten
hier immer viel mehr Leute rein.
Aber warten wir einfach mal.
Vielleicht ist es auch einfach noch zu früh.
Das könnte natürlich auch sein.
Dass 9 Uhr sonntags vielleicht einfach ein bisschen früh ist für die meisten Leute.
Das gehen wir weg.
So, dann machen wir den ganzen Krempel hier mal aus von gestern.
Alles hier, okay, das lässt sich gar nicht mehr ausschauen.
Das ist broken.
Broken AF.
kaputt macht aber nix wir machen jetzt package updates und dann reboot
hier nochmal
ach ja um jetzt hat er abgebrochen okay
mal ob es hier updates gibt keine updates keine updates reboot
irgendwas hängt da im hintergrund was auch merkwürdig ist ich muss ja einmal die vm hier
also nach dem restart muss ich einmal task manager auf und zu machen das vmware entbackt
auch merkwürdig. Der Twitch, was ist denn los? Irgendwie hat Twitch noch nicht so richtig
mitgekriegt, dass der Stream on ist. Sehr weird champ. Ist er schon 6 Minuten on?
irgendwelche probleme ich frame jobs oder sowas
disk space weil available 0 mb das ist jetzt gut oder schlecht
weil ganz abgesehen das stimmt überhaupt nicht
Da pennen alle noch, kann auch sein
Was auch immer
So, guckt, jetzt buggt es gleich
Wenn ich jetzt meinen Desktop starte
Das ist ganz weird in der neuen Version
Jetzt starte ich den Desktop
Okay, geht
So, und jetzt kann ich
Seht ihr, ich kann nicht mehr aus der VM raus
Der einzige Weg
wie ich...
Kaneloni?
Nee.
Kaneloni. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Pog Subscription.
Der einzige Weg,
wie ich jetzt hier wieder rauskomme, ist, wenn ich einmal
den Task Manager aufmache und dann geht's
wieder. Das ist total kaputt.
Das ist seit ich
abgegradet hab hier auf
Vmware 25. Das ist ja die
neueste Version, die sogar kostenlos mittlerweile ist.
Moin.
Kostet ja gar...
Kostet mittlerweile ja nix mehr.
Ich zeige euch mal, das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Also hatten wir ja öfters hier die Frage schon, was ich benutze zum Virtualisieren und sonst
was.
Und es gibt jetzt vor allem eine Workstation.
Vor allem eine Workstation gibt es jetzt kostenlos.
Oh, komm mal hier.
Ich will vor allem eine Workstation Pro downloaden.
Da muss man sich so einen hässlichen Broadcom Account machen.
Aber keine Sorge Leute, ihr müsst nicht wirklich einen Broadcom Account machen.
Die können einfach hier sagen, 10-Minute-Mail und euch hier retten.
Sag mal, wie hässlich möchte eigentlich eine Seite sein?
Ach, das liegt an meinem Darkreader, ha?
Ja.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, die Seite ist ohne Darkreader auch nicht viel schöner, oder?
Anfang 2000er haben angerufen bei der Webseite.
Es ist übrigens auch geil, diese Broadcom-Seite, ne?
Wenn man hier auf download klickt wird man ja zum sign in weitergeleitet wenn man noch keine account hat ist die große preisfrage
Wo ist eigentlich der register button
Ich habe noch keine account für mich registern wo ist der register button
register button gibt es nicht da muss die um auf login klicken und dann register also keine ahnung wer auch immer diese seite designt hat
So und jetzt kann man sich hier einfach
Registern mit irgendeiner 10-Minute-Mail-Adresse
Und dann geht das auch
Okay, zack, next
Oh ja, yeah
Bons, Seite, Neuladen
Und irgendwann kriegt man dann hier die
Oh, ja, ja, ist ja gut
Irgendwann kriegt man dann hier die Antwort von Broadcom
Die haben das nicht geblockt
Also so habe ich das gemacht
für ich ja ja ist ja gut klickt nicht oft zu oft auf ja und dann könnt ihr euch vor
allem bei workstation kostenlos runterladen eigentlich richtig nice stell doch den
keyboard shortcut ja das ist eine gute idee aber ich weiß dass ich bis dahin wenn ich dann
mal brauch den keyboard shortcut eh vergessen habe also irgendwas stimmt mit twitch heute
nicht okay gibt zwei möglichkeiten mit twitch und stream benachrichtigungen stimmt was nicht
oder ich bin einfach viel zu früh.
Wahrscheinlich eine Kombination.
Ich bin zu früh und irgendwas mit den Benachrichtigungen.
Das stimmt nicht.
Normalerweise dauert es irgendwie 2-3 Minuten
und da sind hier die üblichen Verdächtigen schon
im Chat.
So.
Hab ich jetzt meine Mail gekriegt?
Anscheinend nicht.
Leute, ich sag euch,
ich hab das selbst gemacht mit 10-Minute-Mail.
Also anscheinend mag das
gerade nicht. Whatever.
Resend.
Die Broadcom Seite ist so scheiße Leute.
Das ist wahrscheinlich im Hintergrund abgekackt irgendwie und deswegen kam die Mail nicht.
KatziTV Moin.
Puzzle Meister, danke schön für den Sub.
Massive Subscription.
error kann access property 0 v punkt eros ist an die fein
was ist denn wenn ich jetzt am 1 zurück der zurück button geht gar nicht mehr das
ist das komplett problem wenn da ja stelle vor patch tag ist ach ihr macht das samstags
wobei
bei uns ist das auch manchmal am Wochenende
wobei ich meistens am Wochenende nichts machen muss
ich habe am Wochenende
öfters nur Rufbereitschaft
und hoffe dann passiert nichts
übrigens letztes Wochenende auch nice
letztes Wochenende hatte ich Rufbereitschaft
haben sie beantragt, Samstag und Sonntag
und es kam dann
am Samstag
eine Mail
dass die Rufbereitschaft
für Sonntag nicht mehr gebraucht wird.
So, jetzt ist es aber so,
dass du bei uns die Rufbereitschaft
mindestens, glaube ich, sieben Tage im Vorfeld ankündigen musst.
Und, oder noch, ich weiß es gar nicht genau,
wann du sie ankündigen musst.
Zumindest musst du sie, glaube ich,
bis zu drei Tagen vor dem Start musst du sie absagen,
wenn du sie nicht mehr haben willst.
Irgendwie so gibt es eine Regelung.
Und das haben sie nicht gemacht.
Das heißt, ich hatte Sonntag keine Rufbereitschaft,
habe aber trotzdem geld für die rufbereitschaft gekriegt
Ohne schlechter
Und es ist und es gar nicht war und es gar nicht mal zu knapp also wochenend rufbereitschaft kriegt gibt richtig gibt richtig kohle
So ich registriere mich jetzt nicht alle die seite
Aber die Broadcom-Seite sieht allgemein ziemlich mies aus.
Dachte die wollten...
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Haben sie schon gemacht.
Also bezahlen ist ja nicht...
Das kommt ganz normal mit meiner normalen Gehaltsabrechnung.
Aber ich muss das tatsächlich dann eintragen noch, ja?
Also...
Rufbereitschaft machen alleine bei uns bringt dir noch kein Geld.
Du musst danach so einen...
Wer hätte es gedacht, ja?
Ja, musst danach noch so einen Excel ausfüllen, dass du das gemacht hast.
Und dann kriegst du deine Kohle mit der nächsten Gehaltsabrechnung.
Warum das ein Excel ist und nicht über die normale Zeiterfassung geht, keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich, wie man so schön sagt, historisch gewachsen.
Das wurde mal mit Excel angefangen und jetzt sagen die wahrscheinlich, das war schon immer Excel, das bleibt auch Excel.
gehe ich jetzt einfach mal von aus.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich das noch erleben werde,
dass sich das ändert.
Habe ich eigentlich schon rebooted?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
So, mal über Tee trinken.
Sonst kriege ich so einen trockenen Hals.
Und ich muss mal meine
Nackenstütze hier ordentlich machen.
Die hängt jetzt eher im Rücken
als im Nacken. Das ist nicht so bequem.
und dann würde ich sagen dann gucken wir mal was auf shithub so trendet wusste sie eigentlich dass
github ursprünglich eine ruby on rails anwendung war nicht geht lab geht lab ist es glaube ich
immer noch. GitHub.
GitHub ist als Ruby on Rails
Projekt entstanden.
Ruby.
Trending.
Muss den ordentlichen Bürostuhl holen.
Ja, beste.
Beste.
Jede Variante
ist nicht kostenlos.
Also, ich glaube, du kannst ESX und sowas auch kostenlos installieren, aber dort fehlt dir irgendwie Zeug.
Keine Ahnung, kenn ich mich nicht so mit aus.
Ne, ne, es ist definitiv nicht kostenlos, weil ich hab das ja auf der Arbeit mitgekriegt, wie es mit Broadcom und Lizensierungskosten und so aussieht.
Das ist alles andere als kostenlos.
Da bezahlst du verdammt viel Geld für.
Was kostenlos ist für private Nutzung, hier ist es vor allem bei Workstation.
Professional.
Ich muss euch aber auch sagen, ich finde es ehrlich gesagt sogar auch gerechtfertigt, dass das mittlerweile kostenlos ist, weil die haben gefühlt an vor allem der Workstation die letzten 10 Jahre kaum was gemacht.
Kann jemand einen guten Stuhl empfehlen? Ja, kann ich. Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Stuhl im Chat.
Oder ich mach das mal, warte mal. Stuhl.
Gibt's einen Link, guck mal da.
Hä?
Was ist das für ein...
Was ist das für ein bescheuertes Ding von Amazon, dass man da auf weiter klicken muss?
Der hier, der ist extremely pog.
Das einzige Problem an dem ist, also den habe ich auch,
das einzige Problem an dem ist, dass er nicht ganz billig ist.
Aber ansonsten
Ist das
Der beste Stuhl, den ich je hatte
Und auch den Stuhl, den ich die nächsten Jahre weiterverwenden werde
Und wenn der kaputt geht, kaufe ich ihn mir nochmal
Das Poggers Chair
Und was richtig nice ist
Der hat so
Man sieht es hier vielleicht ein bisschen
Die Armlehnen, die sind dreidimensional
Für den Preis bekommt man doch einen Hermann Miller
und es mir doch egal der hier ist viel nicer warum soll ich irgendein random stuhl ausprobieren den
ich nicht kenne wenn ich weiß dass der hier einfach pock ist es kommt natürlich immer so
ein bisschen auf die individuelle individuellen rücken und und wie man sitzt an weil welcher
stuhl der beste ist aber ich kenne keinen besseren stuhl und was bei dem richtig nice ist du kannst
die diese lehnen kannst du dreidimensional einstellen kannst du hier runter einstellen
vorne, hinten, links, rechts und schräg.
Dadurch.
Weil ich hab beispielsweise gerne
die rechte Lehne ein bisschen weiter vorne
und ein bisschen schräg und die linke ein bisschen weiter hinten.
Wobei, das kannst du bei anderen Stühlen auch machen.
Ein bisschen nach außen versetzt.
Weil ich will ja die Armlehne
quasi da haben, wo ich auch die Maus hab.
Ne?
Was hier bewegen kann, gescheit.
Also.
Beste.
Du verwendest die Armlehnen nie, echt?
Wenn das permanent
Armlehnen beste.
Also der ist top.
Den kann ich wirklich empfehlen.
Das ist auch der einzige Bürostuhl,
wo ich wirklich sagen kann,
so ruhigen Gewissens, Leute,
wenn ihr euch den kauft, ihr werdet da
hundertprozentig zufrieden sein.
Der ist einfach nice.
Was ich davor hatte,
davor hatte ich so einen komischen DX-Racer-Stuhl,
der auseinandergebrochen ist, also wirklich
wortwörtlich, ja, ist der auseinandergebrochen.
Das war nix.
Und
davor
weiß ich gar nicht mehr, was ich hatte.
Keine Ahnung, alles Schrott, der ist pock.
Einzige Problem bei dem ist, dass er ziemlich teuer ist.
Ist aber auch nicht schlimm, wenn man
sich mal überlegt, wir verdienen unser Geld
mit vom Computer sitzen, ja, und wir
sitzen viel vorm Computer und für was man
andere Sachen sonst für massig
Geld ausgibt, kann man
sich das auch mal gönnen, finde ich.
Und wenn ihr jetzt sagt, ey, ich will keine 2000 Euro für einen Bürostuhl ausgeben, ja gut, guckt mal nach dem Angebot, da gibt es den vielleicht noch ein bisschen billiger.
Oder, was immer geht, der Klassiker, Ikea, wie heißt das Ding, Markus? Ikea Markus? War das nicht so?
Ja, das ist doch so der Klassiker, den total viele Leute haben hier, Ikea Markus.
Wobei, den hatte ich nie, keine Ahnung, da kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Moin, RF-Programmer.
Ganzer Arm liegt auf dem Tisch.
Ja, ich hab nicht meinen ganzen Arm auf dem Tisch liegen.
Ich hab ungefähr 50% auf dem Tisch liegen.
Die hintere Hälfte liegt auf der Armlehne.
Die ist aber fast auf der gleichen Höhe wie die Tischplatte.
Und dementsprechend kann ich halt auch hier so mit dem Arm bewegen.
Also, ja.
Ist halt Gewöhnungssache.
Backforce V+.
Also es gibt bestimmt noch mehr ganz gute Stühle.
Aber das ist halt der einzige, den ich wirklich aus eigener Erfahrung empfehlen kann.
Den hier.
Sogar mit Reffling.
Kriege ich auch 2,50 Euro von.
Wobei ich den ganz ehrlich wahrscheinlich nicht über Amazon kaufen würde.
Den Stuhl.
Sondern wahrscheinlich bei irgendeinem Büroshop oder so.
Da gibt es auch öfters mal Angebote.
Twitter war auch ursprünglich die Ruby on Rails Anwendung.
So, gucken wir mal, was denn so auf GitHub trendet.
Achso, und wer VMware für Mac verwendet, falls wir irgendwelche Mac-Users hier am Start haben,
das ist mittlerweile auch kostenlos.
Einzige, was man machen muss, man muss sich, das ist ja fast,
ich meine, das ist fast noch schlimmer als kaufen, ja,
aber man muss sich auf dieser hässlichen Broadcom-Seite halt registrieren.
Hier, da.
Und habt ihr eben gerade schon gesehen, ich wollte mich registrieren,
das ist direkt abgekackt beim Registrierungsprozess.
Also die Broadcom-Seite ist wirklich echt
absoluter Shit.
So.
Also, was trendet denn diese Woche so auf GitHub?
AI.
Okay, Blockchain und AI.
Wobei, Blockchain gibt es ja kaum noch hier.
AI eher.
Werden wir mal ignorieren heute wieder.
AI, AI, AI.
AI.
Nicht AI.
Juckt mich aber nicht
AI, ne, ne
Ah, VMs, das kenne ich, das habe ich schon mal
gesehen
AI
Ein Terminal Discord
Client
Das musst du dir mal angucken
Wahrscheinlich werde ich es nie verwenden, aber
das finde ich nice, wobei Discord sagt ja
glaube ich in ihren TOS-Bedingungen,
dass man eigentlich keine Third-Party-Clients
verwenden darf. Auf der anderen Seite
ist halt auch die Frage, wen juckt's?
Discordo.
Lightweight, secure
and feature-rich Discord-Terminal-Client.
Aha.
Es ist cool, dass das geht.
Ich frage mich gerade so ein bisschen, was der Anwendungszweck ist von einem Terminal-Discord-Client.
Also warum will ich Discord im Terminal machen?
Voice-Chat wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Oder kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das funktioniert.
Wahrscheinlich nur Chat.
Und für die ganzen Leute, die alles im Terminal haben wollen, okay, verstehe ich.
Aber ansonsten...
Ich wüsste jetzt, also...
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, ehrlich gesagt, warum...
Warum ich Discord im Terminal haben will.
Weil es ist jetzt nicht so, dass der Discord-Client das Beste ever ist.
Der fühlt sich mittlerweile echt richtig bloated an.
aber ob da so ein Terminal Client jetzt die
beste Alternative zu ist, weiß nicht
es gibt übrigens
immer noch ein paar Sachen, die mich richtig nerven an Discord
wenn ich das mal mit Teamspeak vergleiche
von früher, also ich rede jetzt nicht über
die Standardsachen von wegen
äh äh äh Voice Qualität und
Latency und sowas, das ja okay
ne was mich nervt ist, dass die
Audio Chat oder Voice Audio
Chat oder Voice Chat Features
teilweise so nicht existent sind
zum Beispiel, was richtig nice wäre
wenn man einen großen Voice-Chat-Channel hat, dass man dann sagen könnte, so Moderationsmodus quasi, dass man sagen könnte, ey, alle muted, außer einer.
Das geht in Discord nicht.
Und gerade wenn man größere Rates hat, in einem MMO oder PvP macht mit vielen Leuten oder sowas,
dann ist es einfach kacke
wenn random
bei irgendwelchen Leuten im Hintergrund
die Kinder rumschreien, die Frau ins Zimmer
kommt und rummeckert
irgendwelche Leute das Mikrofon
im Montag haben
oder irgendwie das Mikrofon im Poppes stecken
haben und es ist einfach nervig
die ganzen random Geräusche
und nervigen Sachen, die da immer so aufploppen
dabei will ich ja eigentlich nur den Leader
hören, was er so sagt
und das gibt es in Discord nicht
ne, das geht nicht
also wenn das wenn das in discord geht dann sagt mir wie wer da ist aber ich
habe da schon eine weile es gibt es nicht was geht ist was man machen kann
ist man kann so alternative disco clients verwenden gibt es ja ein paar
aufgetappt
da gibt es gibt es ein paar und da gibt es manche manche mit plugins und da kann
man so was vielleicht machen aber im offiziellen discord klein sehe ich da kein weg für
ok komm mal weiter engine x proxy manager okay das ding ist wirklich nice das habe ich bei mir
daheim auch für zertifikate beste engine x proxy er könnte in die in die mienen screenshot rein
machen weil das hat auch ein hübsches ui gar nicht verkehrt wenn man das sehen würde
ich finde generell read me's mit screenshots immer massive superior gegen read me's wo einfach nur
text drin ist das war jetzt bescheuert hat den glückssatz aber ihr wisst wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich, was ich meine. Also Readme ist mit Screenshots
immer beste.
Container D trendet.
Wir müssen übrigens demnächst
nochmal unsere Go-Geschichte hier erweitern.
Falls sich noch einer dran erinnert.
Wir haben ja hier letztens, ähm...
Oder auch nicht.
Äh, wo haben wir das denn?
hier das hier leicht war dass das
nee das war nur die haben noch so ein prometheus exporter letztens gebaut wo
habe ich in den hin dann habe ich doch sogar gepusht auf moni der monitoring
champ ist es oder genau wo man auch angefangen haben das in java nachzubauen
screenshots sind super nice für für dieses jahr und zwar müssen wir hier
noch ein bau genau das ding meine ich hier müssen wir noch einbauen
ich habe dieses ding so also so ähnlich ja nicht exakt das teil ich auf der
arbeit laufen und die wollen jetzt dass man die major page als statistik die der
kabel die nix köln bereitstellt dass man die als metrik exportiert major page
falls sind ich hoffe in chat falls jemand ahnung hat sagt wenn ich misst
mist erzähle ja das ist glaube ich wenn du sachen aus dem ram lesen willst die
aber nicht mehr im rahmen sind und deswegen von der disk geladen werden
müssen also die quasi geswappt wurden das sind glaube ich major page falls
also wenn er geswappt hat oder das ausgelagert hat irgendwie auf die disk
und du das lesen willst so und sagt er ist aber kann ich im rahmen ich musste
erst mal von einem Disc holen. So und das
ist irgendeine Statistik,
worüber man Aussagen treffen
kann, ob die Software,
die auch in diesem Container läuft und
in diesem Pod läuft, Probleme hat.
Keine Ahnung.
Finde ich auch merkwürdig, aber
es ist wirklich wohl so.
Und das
müssen wir da noch einbauen.
Okay. Hier gibt es eine Discord
FAQ, zeige ich mal her.
Who can speak in a stage channel?
Ja, Moment mal, dann muss das ein extra Channel sein, der so konfiguriert ist.
Was ich meine, ist ein normaler Channel, wo ich sagen kann, alles muten, außer...
Das hier muss ja quasi so ein Managed Channel sein.
Das ist das Einzige, ich will den muten.
Ich will sagen, ey, also das ist ein ganz normaler offener Channel.
Ich will sagen, mute mir alles, außer den da.
und das geht normalen Channels nicht
das suckt
generell finde ich ist die
Voice Chat Funktionalität von Discord
irgendwie
sehr, was soll man sagen, so basic
einfach nur, was wahrscheinlich auch die
Stärke von Discord ist irgendwo, weil
es checkt halt jeder
Also wenn es da mir geht, könnten die durchaus noch ein bisschen mehr Features unterstützen, was Voice Chat angeht.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
TypeScript.
Alertment. Gab es da eine neue Version? Warum trendet der die Woche?
AI.
Nicht AI.
Wie viel AI war da jetzt drin bei den GitHub-Projekten?
Die Hälfte, oder?
Die Hälfte war locker AI.
Eins, zwei, drei, warte mal.
Vier.
Fünf.
Sechs.
Sieben.
Acht, neun.
Ja, das ist ungefähr die Hälfte.
Das ist AI.
Dann gucken wir noch mal was anderes.
Dann gucken wir mal, was bei Go so trendet.
Ich glaube, es gibt irgendwas Spannendes Neues.
Ja, das hatten wir alles schon.
Das hatten wir alles schon.
Okay.
Glanz.
Guck mal.
Keploi.
Weiß ich nicht, was es sein soll.
Crossplane.
ist wirklich sehr
pog. Ich habe gehört,
das wollen sie bei uns auf der Arbeit jetzt auch
testweise einführen.
Crossplane ist quasi sowas
wie Terraform, nur
dass es in Kubernetes
läuft. Kann man jetzt wirklich schwer
erklären.
Muss man sich mal angucken. Ist aber
wirklich extrem nice, weil du kannst
Custom Resource Definitions in Kubernetes
verwenden, um Sachen anzulegen, die halt nichts mit
Kubernetes zu tun haben. Du kannst dann quasi
eine im kubernetes jammel schreibst du dann rein ich will eine postkostenbank haben und crossplan
geht dann her und professionierte eine postkostenbank mit bei google mit cloud sql zum beispiel also das
ist quasi ein terraform was mit kubernetes ressourcen gefüttert werden kann das eigentlich
wirklich sehr sehr nah ist aber gar nicht so verbreitet
so docker docker trendet okay was ist das navi traum vpn
Zui.
Ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
External Secrets Provider. Ja, gut.
Terraform selbst.
Chat, hat das jemand von euch verfolgt?
Wie ist denn jetzt so gerade das...
Wie nennt man das so? Das Momentum?
Was Terraform und Open Tofu angeht.
Was ist denn das, auf was man jetzt...
Also wenn man jetzt neu anfangen würde, irgendwas aufzubauen, so from scratch,
würde man dann eher Terraform oder eher OpenTofu verwenden?
Also OpenTofu, für die Leute, die es nicht mitgekriegt haben, ist ein Terraform-Fork.
Das wurde vor ungefähr, ich sag jetzt mal ungefähr zwei Jahren oder so,
wurde das geforkt, weil HashiCorp irgendwelche komischen Lizenzbedingungen, glaube ich, bei Terraform geändert hat.
daraufhin gab es dann Open Tofu
und Terraform wurde halt auch parallel weiterentwickelt
und damals hatte Open Tofu ziemliches Momentum
so nach dem Motto, alle, oh scheiße auf Terraform
wir machen jetzt Open Tofu
aber mittlerweile habe ich ganze Weile
nichts mehr von Open Tofu gehört
jedem tut es das aber noch
und wird auch immer noch entwickelt
so, keine Ahnung
sales
obentor vorhat mit auch bald die firma resource ist dass das einst ja was
würdet ihr jetzt nehmen
high iq chat was würdet ihr neben angenommen ihr sagt jetzt okay ich fange
jetzt was ist auch ein topf ist ein terraform fork den es vor ungefähr zwei
jahren gegeben hat weil terraform damals irgendwas an die lizenzbedingungen
geändert hat, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe.
Wenn ihr jetzt anfangen würdet, würdet ihr dann lieber
sagen, okay, scheiße, auf Terraform, ich nehme Open
Tofu oder weiter bei Terraform bleiben?
Also ich tendiere ja immer dabei,
zu sagen, ey, man nimmt erstmal das, was das
verbreitetere ist
und wahrscheinlich würde ich dann bei Terraform
bleiben, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Ich finde es traurig, wie scheiße Teams nach 5 Jahren ist.
Ach, Teams geht doch. Ich meine, die haben
Teams ja jetzt neu entwickelt und angeblich ist Teams
jetzt ja viel schneller und mehr Performance
und sowas. Ich merke
davon nichts. Ich finde, es ist mittlerweile genauso lahm
wie früher auch. Fragt man
sich halt, wie lahm Teams eigentlich wäre, wenn
sie die alte Teams-Version weiterbehalten hätten.
Aber ansonsten geht Teams doch klar.
Ich finde, Teams
kann man, ich finde, Teams kann man
so beschreiben. Teams ist
so das kleinere
Übel, was so
Chat und Messaging Programme
angeht.
Ich muss manchmal Zoom verwenden
auf der Arbeit, weil einer unserer Dienstleister,
die für uns so eine,
die programmieren für uns was und ab und zu haben wir
mit denen so einen Austauschtermin und die machen
diesen Austauschtermin mittlerweile
gerne über Zoom.
Und Zoom kriege ich immer richtig
Anfälle. Das muss ich im Browser
verwenden.
Zoom ist Skype auf Wish bestellt.
das sagt man doch heute gar nicht mehr oder auf wish bestellt sehr themen thema ist es ja auch
nicht mehr oder thema ist glaube ich auch schon wieder out ich weiß was du meinst also so kriege
ich immer anfälle weil so muss ich im browser verwenden weil wir keinen zoom desktop klein
ins ziel gibt es überhaupt eine zoom desktop klein wahrscheinlich und da kackt ja mal ein mikrofon
ab das funst immer nicht richtig ich muss sagen ganz ehrlich java ist richtig nice für das was
es ist ansonsten ist es in der heutigen zeit finde ich nicht mehr so richtig brauchbar also
wir hatten früher also ganz ganz früher als ich noch beim internet provider gearbeitet habe also
das ist wirklich ganz ganz lange her da hatten wir als chat und als kleines kennt das noch jemand
war noch jemand pitchen als als chat client kennt das noch jemand will zeigen ja so sah das so sah
das damals aus das hatten wir damals als chat klein
pitchen mit ja sowas hier pitchen mit jabber
so sah das aus xx mpp das ist ja und er konnte damals auch icq noch als
protokoll die ein bisschen aus wie ts ja ein bisschen naja nee wir pitchen
das war noch lange vor skype oder gar teams oder sowas und das hat ziemlich
gut funktioniert ohne scheiß das war schnörkellos und hat einfach
funktioniert man hatte einen encryption plugin sogar drin dass die das deck dass
der ganze chat verlauf entwickler zwar
also das als pitchen also für die für die zeit da wir reden hier von 2007 ja
für die zeit damals war pitchen mit java war echt nice
darf sie nicht installieren was du meinst den du meinst den zoom den zoom
Desktop-Client. Ne, darf ich nicht installieren.
Es ist bei uns... Ey, Leute, ich krieg
da immer Anfälle, ne?
Das Notebook bei mir auf der Arbeit.
Ich bin ja gezwungen, ein Windows-Notebook
zu verwenden. Da hab ich mich ja schon öfters
drüber aufgeregt.
Ich muss ja ein Windows-Notebook
verwenden. Das macht auch Sinn.
Also, unabhängig davon, dass ich das nicht mag
und lieber eine Linux-Kiste verwenden würde,
macht's insofern Sinn. Die wollen halt,
dass alle die gleichen Sachen installiert
haben und die gleichen Voraussetzungen
erfüllen und alles und automatische
Sachen wie 2-Faktor-Authentifizierung
funktionieren.
Ich gette das schon so ein bisschen, warum
wir alle dieses eklige Windows-Notebook verwenden
müssen. Macht schon Sinn.
Trotzdem regt es mich regelmäßig
auf, dass ich dieses komische Windows-Notebook
da verwenden muss.
Ich darf da drauf selbstverständlich nichts installieren,
was nicht in unserem
Software-Management drin ist und Zoom
ist da nicht drin.
und was mich am meisten nervt sind die 100.000 Sachen, die da drauf sind.
Wenn ich auf meinem Arbeitsnotebook hier unten die Taskleiste aufklappe,
dann sind hier, keine Ahnung, 8 Zeilen Icons oder so drin.
Das Fenster hier unten geht bei mir fast den halben Bildschirm lang.
So viel läuft da im Hintergrund.
und als ich das erste mal das notebook bekommen habe da war das noch windows 10 und bei windows
10 war das so eingestellt dass das hier nicht minimiert war sondern sondern ausgefahren war
da hatte ich ohne scheiß ist jetzt wirklich ungelogen hatte ich eigens von hier bis hier
80 prozent der taskleiste war trey icons topics dankeschön für den sub 80 du musst mich mal
vorstellen oder ob bis hier du hast kein platz für normale programme gehabt da läuft so viel
zeug im hintergrund und das ist lahm es fakt obwohl das eigentlich ziemlich power ziemlich
starkes notebook ist das sind notebooks mit 32 g gramm mit acht kern acht kern cpu relativ neu
ordentlichen bei sich nicht zwei terabyte es heißt der sind wirklich gute notebooks das ist
nicht so dass das ding jetzt irgendwie auf dem flohmarkt zusammengebaut worden wäre aber das
ist lahm das ist so lahm weil also 1000 1000 sachen im hintergrund ja ja da acht wahrscheinlich
laufen da acht viren scanner und und sonst was im hintergrund wie ich das mittlerweile mache
ist ich habe eine linux kiste ich habe ich habe eine linux vm der habe ich auch richtig richtig
dampf verpasst ja also die hat auch 88 cpu kerne weil sie nicht 16 oder sind 32 g gramm also hat
ordentlich power und ich benutze mein notebook eigentlich nur noch um mich auf die linux vm
einzuloggen und dann hole ich mir per x-format ding anders funktioniert es
nicht also hier wo wir beim thema wayland und so was sind weil es da
wahrscheinlich die nächsten 50 jahren gegeben auf einer fall hole ich mir das
hole ich mir dann einfach rüber per x-format ding und macht dann alles da
drin weil alles andere hältst du nicht aus und auf der linux kiste habe ich
Admin-Rechnung kann alles machen.
Da kann ich dann
beispielsweise auch mal einen Wireshark drauf starten
oder sowas und mir Netzwerk-Dump
angucken. Was meint ihr, was es für ein Akt
ist, bis ich Wireshark bekomme? Wisst ihr, was es für ein
Akt ist, bei uns Wireshark
zu bekommen? Das gibt's gar
nicht für normale Notebooks.
Okay, ich erzähl euch das jetzt mal.
Wenn ich Netzwerk-Dumps
analysieren will,
dann muss ich, dass ich Wireshark bekomme,
muss ich mir erst mal
eine Admin-VM
beantragen. Da bekomme ich
dann eine Windows-Kiste.
Ja, da beschwert sich
keiner. Ich hänge es auch nicht so an die große Glocke,
aber wir haben
viele Leute haben Linux-VMs. Das ist okay.
Das ist abgesegnet.
So, da muss ich erstmal
eine Admin-VM, eine Windows-Admin-VM
beantragen, dass ich
Wireshark bekommen kann. Das dauert dann ein bisschen, dann kriegt man eine
Windows-Admin-VM. Und dann muss ich
auf die Windows-Admin-VM.
Dort
habe ich dann über Citrix, also per Citrix kann ich da nur drauf, das leckt eh schon mal rum,
dann muss ich dort über irgendein Browser isoliertes, ne Schwachsinn, das stimmt ja gar nicht,
ich kann Wireshark von dort ja gar nicht richtig runterladen, ich muss dann auf meine normale VM gehen,
dort Wireshark runterladen, auf den Windows-Share schieben, auf den Windows-Share gehe ich dann von meiner Admin-VM drauf,
Auf der Admin-VM installiere ich dann Wireshark und dann schiebe ich mir die Netzwerk-Dumps über den Windows-Share auch darüber.
So, und dann kann ich das in Wireshark aufmachen, die Netzwerk-Dumps.
Das ist wirklich total abartig.
Deswegen habe ich einfach jetzt meine Linux-VM, da starte ich Wireshark drin und gut ist, bei X-Forwarding funktioniert das alles.
Deswegen bin ich überhaupt kein Fan von, wie da die Entwicklung bei Linux zur Zeit geht,
dass manche sogar denken, X-Support zu droppen.
Ich bin aufgeschmissen, wenn es keinen X-Support mehr gibt.
Mit Wayland wird da nichts.
Das höchste, das einzige, was ich machen könnte, ist vielleicht irgendein ONC oder so.
Oder irgendein RDP oder sowas installieren.
Wobei ich gar nicht weiß, funktioniert eigentlich
Moment mal, funzt eigentlich
Das ist eine gute Frage, funzt
Wayland RDP, funzt das eigentlich zusammen?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Geht das? Das müssen wir hier mal ausprobieren
Aber da geht der Trend hin
Mein X ist auch Müll
Ich verstehe das ja, dass die sagen
Ey, das Ding ist so oldschool, bloated und unwartbar
Aber meistens
Und das sieht man auch bei Wayland wieder
Meistens ist ein kompletter Rewrite
From scratch nicht die beste Variante
Wozu hat das jetzt geführt?
Dass X quasi
Komplett stagniert ist
Die letzten 20 Jahre
Und dass Wayland noch nicht mal annähernd
X ersetzen kann.
Also ist auch kacke.
Ja.
Sackt.
So.
Und was ich auch noch gucken will, was trendet,
ist, was die Sharp trendet.
Ob es da irgendwas Spannendes gibt.
Was soll das sein?
Chinakinesen-Zeug.
Muss ich mal aufhören zu verstehen.
Bitworn.
AI.
Nee, Trading Engine.
Aspire trendet.
Chat, ich muss mich mal als Noob
jetzt outen.
Kann mir irgendjemand erklären,
wofür ich Aspire brauche?
Ich habe dazu schon 1-2 Webcasts gesehen.
Ich habe es nicht gecheckt.
Das war ja früher .NET Aspire
und ich bin ein .NET Fanboy,
aber ich checke
legit nicht, wofür ich Aspire
brauchen würde.
Was mir das...
Wann würde ich Aspire benutzen?
Check ich nicht.
Und die Erklärung bei Microsoft ist halt auch ein bisschen
Fail.
Your stack streamlined.
Orchestrate frontend, APIs, Container,
Database...
Das ist so abstrakt, da weiß ich auch nicht,
was sie von mir wollen.
Also ich bin da
zu noob.
Ich checke nicht, wozu ich ein Spire brauche.
Vielleicht
checkt das ja einer von euch.
Der CPU-Set-Setter.
Ah ja.
Ach so, dass es auf den richtigen
CPU-Kern läuft.
Der CPU-Set-Setter.
Ein DNS-Server für C-Sharp
trendet.
Aha.
R3, das verstehe ich, dass das trennt.
Das ist nice.
Das ist React...
Rx.net
Fork.
ShareX, das ist ein Screenshot-Programm.
Nicht zu verwechseln mit XShare.
Okay, nix so Spannendes hier.
Was soll das bitte schon sein?
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Moment, wir müssen das mal kurz übersetzen.
Translate to English.
Can be used for ageless
legit...
legitimes...
Aussprache, Pog.
Defense against networks mit
lauschen und...
Was?
ist was soll das sein
nach englisch mit desktop s&e konzern tool based on was für ein ding
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was das sein sollte.
Was, was?
Okay.
Da bin ich zu low IQ für.
Versteht jemand, was ich hier vor mir habe?
Hackerkram.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keinen Plan, was das sein wird.
weg sagen wir hier clans dashboard immerhin ich wollte gerade sagen wenn die kein screenshot
drin haben dann ist das ganz schön fehl haben screenshot drin ein dashboard brauche ich auch
rated outdated je bated personal streaming service navi drum bestimmt
das ist nur das ist nur für leute wie mich die linux distributionen per torrent
runterladen was anderes lade ich nicht runter ich lade übrigens bei der way
per torrent gar nichts runter und ich habe auch schon wirklich lange also wir
reden hier bestimmt von fünf jahren oder so oder länger keine ahnung habe ich
habe ich auch keine musik oder irgendwas mehr runtergeladen
das geht alles über streaming auch was filme und so angeht also
das einzige was mich bei streaming services abfuckt ist dass man so viele
braucht
also wenn du was wenn du was bestimmtes gucken willst kannst dich nicht mehr
darauf verlassen, dass es das auf deinem Streaming-Service gibt.
Auf der
anderen Seite, was bei Streaming-Services
halt geht, was sie ein bisschen vermeiden wollen,
ist,
ich schließe, also beispielsweise, wenn es bei Netflix
was gibt. Ich habe, ähm,
vor nicht allzu
langer Zeit habe ich Dings hier geguckt,
äh,
das da auf
Netflix.
Bei 2017 ist das schon. Okay, ist ein bisschen her.
Ist ein bisschen her.
Ähm,
Zumindest habe ich einfach dafür ein Netflix-Abo abgeschlossen, habe geguckt und danach habe
ich das Netflix-Abo quasi auslaufen lassen.
Also ich cancel das Netflix-Abo immer direkt nachdem ich es gestartet habe.
Das wollen die natürlich immer so ein bisschen verhindern, so wollen sie nicht bei uns Kunde
bleiben und dann nach Möglichkeit nicht gucken und vergessen, dass sie ein Abo haben.
Ich schließe mein Abo ab und cancel es direkt wieder.
vor prime verwählt wilder igel danke für den sub rock subscription messers ab also
die haftbefehl doku geguckt weil ich gar kein netflix abo habe wenn ich netflix
abo abschließe werde ich mir davon direkt wieder abschließen direkt
canceln und dann gucke ich was ich gucken will und dann gucke ich auch die
Befehl Doku.
Hafti Abi.
Dreirad Monster.
Langschiffel ins Up.
Frankfurt.
Goethe Straße.
Louis Vuitton Store.
Zahl die Kollektion Bar.
Fick auf Spottensor.
So.
Was kann man denn jetzt hier mit Navidro machen?
open source web based music collection server and stream und gibt es musik so also das ist
für die leute die sich linux distribution runtergeladen haben per torrent und die dann
stream wollen hier brauche ich nicht
ich strebe tatsächlich mittlerweile musik nicht über spotify oder amazon
sondern über youtube muss youtube musik weil ich habe ja einen youtube wie heißt
das pro abo oder sowas und da ist das mit dabei
und dafür ist es echt ganz gut also gibt es das meiste was ich hören will
Nee, es geht nicht mehr.
Das geht nicht mehr.
Ich hatte das über Indien abgeschlossen.
Das geht aber nicht mehr.
Leider.
Hat sich einfach nicht mehr verlängern lassen.
Was ziemlich sagt.
Müsste schon wieder probieren, ob das funktioniert.
also ich hatte eine ganze zeit youtube premium über über ein zweites payment profil beziehungsweise
das stimmt nicht ich hatte das nicht nicht meine account count der die nicht mehr teile
und da hat man youtube premium abgeschlossen über indien und das hat
dann irgendwie glaube ich nur drei dollar oder so gekostet drei euro
Hä?
Also, ob ich
YouTube Premium über
über Indien abschließe,
ich glaube, das wird das Finanzamt nicht großartig interessieren.
Was kostet YouTube Premium in Andorra?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Also, ich wohne ja,
auf Twitter wohne ich ja in Andorra.
Und das ist wirklich das Beste, was ich machen konnte, weil ich dann nicht mal diese ekligen Deutschland-Trends auf Twitter sehen muss.
Leider, seitdem Twitter X ist, funktioniert das nicht mehr richtig. Ich sehe die deutschen Trends doch wieder zum größten Teil.
Türkische Apple-Account und hier Gutladen aufladen.
Ah, sehr gute Idee.
Muss ich mir mal überlegen.
weil 16 99 oder was das mittlerweile kostet für youtube premium ist mir
eigentlich ein bisschen viel aber ich muss sagen es ist irgendwo noch okay
gerade so an der schmerzgrenze weil ich gucke halt viel youtube und ich benutze
halt das musik streaming auch den ganzen tag von youtube music also das geht
gerade so aber wirklich gerade so geht das noch okay
Naja, so
Das brauchen wir nicht, zack, weg
So, mal gucken, ob es Package-Updates gibt
Ich weiß, ich habe schon geguckt, aber das ist immerhin schon
45 Minuten her und wir sind auf Arch-Linux
Natürlich gibt's Package-Updates
Moin, Jelaman
Leute, wir haben schon eine Viertelstunde schon keine Package-Updates mehr gemacht
Package-Updates
Reboot
Macht überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass ich reboote, by the way
Macht absolut null Sinn, dass ich jetzt rebooted hab
Egal, wir rebooten jetzt trotzdem
Reboot tut gut
Was wurde?
Knut TLS wurde aktualisiert.
Dazu muss ich garantiert nicht rebooten.
Lala.
So und jetzt ist, guckt Leute,
jetzt ist wieder meine VM gebuckt.
Kann ich wieder nicht aus der VM raus.
Jetzt muss ich wieder einmal den Taskmanager aufmachen.
Und jetzt,
jetzt kann ich hier wieder aus der VM rein raus.
Das ist ein Bug in VMware Workstation 25.
Das hatte die 17er Version, die ich davor hatte, nicht.
Also ziemlicher Sack.
Ach ja, und wisst ihr, was auch ziemlicher Sack ist?
Moment, das funzt.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Nested-Virtualisierung funktioniert hier?
Weil VMware hat Probleme, wenn man Windows 11 hat.
Und die sagen ja, man muss Hyper-V aktivieren, dass VMware richtig funktioniert.
oder man muss es komplett deaktivieren, was nur per Registry-Hacks funktioniert.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt dieses komische Hyper-V-Plugin installiert.
Und jetzt laufen die VMs unter der Haube anscheinend irgendwie in Hyper-V.
Frag mich nicht, wie das genau ist.
Und bei mir ging das mit Nested-Virtualisierung nicht.
Warum geht das mit Nested-Virtualisierung auf einmal hier jetzt?
Ja, früher war 4M Workstation ja auch noch 4M Workstation Virtualisierung.
Mittlerweile ist das irgendwie unter der Haube Hyper-V.
Deswegen hat das mit Nested Virtualisierung nicht funktioniert.
Ich weiß, dass das immer funktioniert hat.
Aber jetzt, weil meine anderen 4M hat das...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wird Manager?
Ich lege mal kurz eine 4M an, irgendeine random 4M.
Und dann gucken wir mal, ob das wirklich funktioniert.
Ob das wirklich funktioniert mit Nested Virtualisierung.
Das dürfte sich jetzt auch mal einkriegen, wäre ganz nice.
Der VM-Champ ist doch kaputt.
Manual Install.
Ich will einfach nur gucken, ob das Ding startet.
Linux.
Hier, einmal Linux, meinetwegen ist mir doch egal.
kein storage prominent perfekt
fremdes gecrasht keck wait oder
Oder? Ne. Hä?
Ja, ne? Von wegen das funktioniert.
Du verstehst nur Bahnhof.
Wir gucken gleich ein paar YouTube-Videos.
Dann verstehst du das wieder.
Was sagst du zu Mario Galaxy
für die Switch 2, das für Switch 1 kam?
Ich finde das gut.
Also ich habe keine Switch 2.
Also meinst du, weil es es auch für die Switch 1 gab?
Ich glaube, die Switch 2 Version ist doch schon
optisch auch noch ein bisschen besser.
Ich finde das aber sehr nice, weil Mario Galaxy
ist
Jetzt ist mein Desktop nicht richtig.
Für mich ist das mein Lieblings-3D-Mario.
Du springst zum Wort.
Kannst doch da bleiben.
jetzt kaputt kann es auch da bleiben danach das wort gucken wie du willst warum ging das jetzt
nicht okay manuel install linux ja ja ja ubuntu ist eigentlich vollkommen egal noch
nix nix nix kein storage finish das ist kaputt nested virtualisierung sage ich doch seit dieser
Hyper-V-Shit unter der
Haube da unter Windows läuft. Fuckt mich das
ab, Alter.
Guck, kaputt.
Vor allem bei Workstation. Unrecoverable
Error.
Bam.
Kaputt ist es.
Kaputt.
So, jetzt
ich hoffe, jetzt kriege ich den Kram wenigstens wieder
im Fullscreen, wenn ich es hier offen habe.
Achso, ja dann,
Dragon's Soul, GLHF.
Ich glaube, ich schalte dieses Hyper-V-Feature
wieder ab und benutze die ganz normale
Vm-Virtualisierung.
Weil das ist doch...
Abfuck. Auf der anderen Seite, wie oft braucht man
Nested-Virtualisierung?
Ja, wie oft...
Hält sich eigentlich in Grenzen, wie oft man Nested-Virtualisierung
braucht.
Aber ist trotzdem Dreck.
Suchen wir nochmal.
Meine VM ist schon wieder weg.
Ist irgendwie broken.
Suchen wir nochmal.
Ich weiß, das ist ein bisschen sidetracked, aber
lass mal gucken.
VMware Workstation
Workstation nested
Virtualisierung Windows 11
kann in der std das hat zu porten der virtualisation okay
das ist in london mit auf fremde workstation windows 11 egal
geht nicht sagt halt ein bisschen
Man kann Hyper-V deaktivieren
Ja das alleine bringt aber nichts
Man braucht noch irgendwelche Registry-Hacks
Was nutzt er?
EveNG.
Was ist EveNG? Ach,
Proxmox oder
whatever.
Hier, das genau,
das muss man machen.
Hier, Turn off Hyper-V
und jetzt muss man
hier BC Edit machen. Genau.
Und dann Core Isolation
irgendwie ausschalten. Windows Security.
Dann
virtualisiert VM wieder mit VM-Virtualisierung
und nicht mehr
mit Hyper-V.
Ich glaube, das werde ich machen, weil das
fuckt mich ab.
Die Tastatur ist auch laggy
hier drinnen.
Also manchmal ist hier,
wenn ich hier, ja, manchmal laggt die Tastatur
hier in der VM.
Das ist echt abartig.
Also die Haftbefehl Doku gesehen ich habe kein Netflix Abo aber sobald ich noch was anderes gucken will auf Netflix
Dann mache ich wieder meine standard Taktik Netflix Abo abschließen
und dann direkt
Abo kündigen und dann gucke ich was ich gucken will und auch die Haftbefehl Doku
Es ist eklig
Die machen die echt das Leben schwer unter Windows, Windows, ne weißt du was noch viel besser ist Windows und Linux zusammen hier zack zack zack zack
Windows, Linux, Windows, Linux, Linux, Windows.
Einfach das verwenden, was für die jeweilige Sache am besten ist.
Problem ist, dass es mit Hyper-V halt ultra sackt.
Ich werde das auch...
Ich schalte Hyper-V-Gedulds wieder aus.
Max, gehst du auf der neuen Arbeit auf die Weihnachtsfeier?
Ich wurde erst wieder im Discord geflammt, weil ich nicht zu meinen...
Ne, mach ich nicht.
Ich bin kein Weihnachtsfeiergänger.
Weiß gar nicht, wann die ist.
Weihnachtsfeier hab ich keinen Bock.
außerdem bin ich ja im dezember immer nicht da da ist das muss ich gar nichts
großartig erklären
außerdem finde ich sollte man das jedem selbst überlassen chat wie ist das bei
euch geht ihr auf die weihnachtsfeier bei eurer firma wo ihr arbeitet oder
nicht und moment moment moment moment bevor er befeuert antwortet wenn ihr
sagt ja wenn ihr sagt ja ja wenn ihr sagt ja ich gehe hin würde mich
interessieren geht er hin weil ihr euch verpflichtet fühlt oder weil ihr bock
drauf habt
also als ich noch azubi war und gedacht habe das gehört sich so dass man auf die
weihnachtsfeier geht da habe ich immer bin ich da nur hingegangen obwohl ich
keinen bock hatte weil ich mich irgendwie da so verpflichtet gefühlt
habe weil ich bock hab geiles essen gut gesellschaft ja auch das ist sind nicht
alle so Kellerkinder wie ich.
Also der einzige Grund, warum ich hingehen würde,
ist tatsächlich, weil es kostenlos viel zu fressen
gibt. Das ist aber auch das Einzige.
Okay, ja.
Sie sehen ja mal
ganz unterschiedlich.
Ganz unterschiedlich. Manche haben überhaupt keinen Bock drauf,
manche gehen hin, weil sie verpflichtet fühlen, manche gehen hin,
weil sie Bock drauf haben.
Also das Essen bei uns ist immer top.
Da kann man nichts sagen.
Dresscode.
Da würde ich auch nicht hinfahren.
Wenn die mich da mit Holzfällerhemd nicht reinlassen, dann wird das nichts.
Ich meine, ich würde immerhin ein Hemd anziehen.
Ja, wäre schon so nett.
Ich würde da nicht im Hoodie kommen.
Aber ich komme da nicht im Anzug.
Ich habe noch nicht mal meinen Anzug, der überhaupt passt.
Vielleicht, wobei, wobei, mittlerweile, ich habe ja insgesamt 25 Kilo abgenommen seit den letzten 5 Jahren, ähm, mittlerweile könnte ich vielleicht sogar wieder reinpassen.
Geh mit Jogginghose, mal, mal, am Hauptbahnhof sich erstmal noch ankotzen lassen oder was?
VR-Frag
Ist das ein VR-Multiplayer-Game oder was?
Das sagt mir nichts
Oder interpretiere ich das jetzt falsch?
Spielt man da irgendein Multiplayer-Spiel oder so?
Virtual Reality-Frag
Mit VR-Headset in einer Halle
Also Multiplayer mit den Leuten zusammen.
Gut, das wird bei uns ein bisschen schwierig.
Das sind hunderte Leute auf der Weihnachtsfeier.
Habe ich gespielt, aber keinen Bock mehr gehabt.
BW2.
Auslosen, bei wem man sitzt.
Das haben sich wieder irgendwelche...
so
nicht BWL-Leute,
so Personalleute ausgedacht,
die der Meinung sind,
oh, das ist doch eine super Gelegenheit,
um zu netzwerken.
Lasst mal Leute auslosen, wie sie sitzen bei der Weihnachtsfeier.
Oh.
Das kann ich mir so richtig vorstellen.
Die haben sich dann darauf abgefeiert,
was für eine geile Idee sie hatten, Alter.
Übelst unangenehm, ja.
Also wenn ich schon auf die Weihnachtsfeier gehe,
dann will ich da auch mit Leuten zusammenhocken, die ich kenne, mit denen ich öfters was zu tun habe.
Ja, nee, das ist nix.
By the way, Leute, ich kann jetzt übrigens Battlefield 6 spielen.
Ich habe ja Windows neu installiert.
Deswegen sieht mein Desktop auch so aufgeräumt aus.
Das liegt ganz einfach daran,
die können sich das nicht vorstellen, dass es das gibt.
Die denken, alle sind so wie sie.
Das ist genauso, wie ich denke.
Alle sind so Kellerkinder wie ich.
Ist ja auch nicht so.
Das ist immer, das ist generell ein Problem von Leuten, dass die hauptsächlich immer von sich ausgehen.
Was ja auch das naheliegendste ist. Alle denken immer, die restliche Welt ist auch so wie ich.
Ne, ich werde nicht mal eine erste Runde Battlefield 6 on Stream spielen, dann sieht man ja, wie schlecht ich mittlerweile bin.
Ich muss erst mal ein bisschen üben, dass das halbwegs anschaubar ist.
Würdest du jemals ein Meetup machen?
Nö
Das Game hat keine Seele
Okay, jetzt redet mir das mal nicht schlecht
Ich hab gedacht, es gibt endlich wieder ein halbwegs gescheites Battlefield
Ne, hab ich nicht ausprobiert
Hab ich auch gar kein großes Interesse dran
Und mal gucken, ob es Package-Updates gibt
Das ist schon 10 Minuten her, wo ich das letzte Package-Update gemacht habe.
Ne, okay, diesmal nicht.
Ark Raiders bockt.
Ich habe das nur am Rande verfolgt.
Ist Ark Raiders ein Extraction-Game oder was ist das?
Das könnte durchaus sein, dass es das geben wird.
Hast du gesehen, wie Commander Krieger abgenommen hat?
Ja, ich habe das letzte Video gesehen. Er hat richtig abgenommen.
Finde ich nice.
Also da kann ich mit meinen 25 Kilo
nicht mithalten. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel
er abgenommen hat, aber auf jeden Fall mehr.
Also das ist wirklich richtig krass.
Extremely Poggers.
Extraction Shooter.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich bin ja auch einer der Boomers,
die sagen, Battlefield 6
hätte kein Battle Royale gebraucht.
Ich weiß, der Lost zum Beispiel,
ist der meinung games ohne battle royale modus das geht ja nicht mehr und so was ich bin der
meinung sie hätten sich voll auf den multiplayer konzentrieren sollen da einfach mehr content noch
liefern vor allem ein bisschen auch ein bisschen mehr maps aber da bin ich wahrscheinlich in der
unter minderheit also ich habe battlefield battle royale gestern paar runden geguckt auf twitch
und das sah für mich auf den ersten blick wie der krasseste war so ein clown überhaupt aus
sogar die kisten sehen genauso aus ja die platten ja wobei die platten hat sie glaube ich sogar ein
Firestorm schon.
Oh.
Das ist, das ist eklig,
Luku, das ist eklig. Ich muss das hier grad mal
vorlesen, weil da kann ich auch was zu sagen.
Ähm, er schreibt
das gleiche bei uns. Unser wöchentliches Meeting
mit siebze... Alter.
Kannst du was kommen? Mit siebzehn Leuten wird jetzt
der meeting leiter durch rotiert damit jeder einmal ein meeting leitet das ist bei uns auch
so unsere team runde da sind wir auch wir sind glaube ich 21 leute also ungefähr so in eurer
größenordnung und da ist es auch so dass jede woche jemand anderes durch das meeting führt
und das protokoll ausfüllt dabei das ist auch nicht sonderlich beliebt gibt nicht viele leute
Leute, die da richtig Bock drauf haben.
Ich hab das aber geschickt gemacht, das letzte
Mal. System Outplayed.
Ich musste das machen.
Und
hab das, hab das, hab das
gemacht, ja, Protokoll.
Und die Woche da drauf
waren gar nicht viele Leute da.
Und derjenige, der dran
war, mit dem Protokoll und
durchs Meeting führen, war nicht da.
Und da hab ich gesagt, ach wisst ihr was,
Leute, ich hab das doch
letzte woche schon gemacht ich mache es einfach die woche noch mal der trick
dahinter war ich wusste das meeting geht plus fünf minuten weil kaum jemand da
ist und dann konnte ich mich doppelt abhaken und muss jetzt für dieses jahr
quasi gar nicht mehr ran
also muss man muss auch manchmal die sachen abpassen so dass es gut zu
vorteil ist ja weil bei uns ist immer so die gruppenrunden gehen wenn nur wenn
nur eine handvoll leute da sind gehen die halt immer total schnell gerade wenn
der chef auch nicht da ist dann geht man einfach zwei drei aktuelle themen durch
was so war was er vertreter mitgekriegt hat und dann war es das und ansonsten
ist natürlich ein bisschen umfangreicher
ja sechs hat outplayed so schau was können wir uns denn auf youtube angucken
Leute, ich habe alle meine Tabs verloren.
Alle Tabs sind weg.
Das.
Alle meine Tabs sind weg, weil ich habe ja Windows neu installiert.
Und habe mein Chrome rübergezogen.
Aber irgendwie hat er nicht meine geöffneten Tabs und meine History und sowas.
weil deswegen habe ich jetzt hier so komische videos hier was ich was ich
empfohlen kriege was ist das hier
was kriege ich hier für videos empfohlen shorts vor allem
steambox release juckt mich überhaupt nicht
was ist das ein westgate the most expensive von brand linux kann so krass aussehen
Okay, das können wir uns angucken.
Also, der einzig wahre
Linux-Rise zur Zeit
scheint ja Hyperland zu sein.
Wenn man jetzt mal hier guckt.
Reddit, Unix-Porn.
Also,
das ist nichts Unanständiges, Leute.
Da zeigen die Leute einfach nur,
wie sie ihre Desktop-Umgebung gepimpt haben.
Und Hyperland, sage ich doch
Da ist total, das ist 90% Hyperland
Hyperland, Hyperland
Hyperland
Und die 3, okay
Klassiker noch, die 3
Hyperland
Also, das ist
Der Shit, den Leute reißen sich kaputt
In Hyperland
Was bei mir leider flach fällt
Weil Wayland
Du hattest doch gestern kurz über Blazer ausgelassen
Hast du dir das kürzlich nochmal onsteam angeschaut?
Ne, hab ich nicht
Hatte ich eigentlich auch nicht vor, weil mich Blazer so voll kalt lässt
Oder meinst du
Es lohnt sich nochmal anzugucken
Neue VM mit Hyperland
Hyperland funzt in der VM nicht richtig.
Weil Wayland.
Alfred, was meinst du?
Lohnt sich das?
Nochmal anzugucken?
Stream-Themen.
Wir fangen mal eine neue Liste an.
Ich hab die alte Liste noch, ja.
Aber wir schreiben mal.
schreiben wir eine neue liste stream themen geht es auch nicht in virtual box
das habe ich nicht ausprobiert aber wird schild box wird wahrscheinlich auch
nicht richtig funktionieren solange ich diesen hyper wie krempel von windows 11
an hab ich muss das unbedingt wieder ausschalten komplett dann läuft auch
dann läuft auch vor allem bei workstation wieder besser hoffe ich mal
und wenn dieser dumme back noch da ist mit diesem dass ich hier nicht full
screen machen kann teilweise oder aus dem full screen rauskomme dann ist er
ich mir einfach wieder vor einer workstation 17 weil damit funktioniert
hast du den neuen steam controller gesehen
kennst du eine methode über charts ausblenden kann
Battlefield 3 war besser.
Ja gut, Battlefield 3 zu toppen
ist auch schwierig. Die haben gar nicht mal
die Leute für...
Lohnt sich das, wenn man schon auf Warzone keinen Bock hatte?
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube Battlefield 6
zu kaufen nur für den Battle Royale Modus
weiß ich nicht.
Ob es das so ist.
Was ist Niri?
Ist das ein Linus Distro oder was ist
Da muss ich mal googeln danach.
Niri Linux.
Scrollable
Ah, Moment mal.
Das ist ne
Das ist ne Hyperland Alternative
oder was?
Display Manager in Rust.
Okay, das speichern wir mal.
Ja, aber das funktioniert nicht richtig.
Wobei, das könnte ich mal in der
VM ausprobieren, ob es gescheit funktioniert.
Weil
Hyperland fund's nicht gescheit
Niri könnten wir mal ausprobieren
Sollen wir mal nach VMware suchen
Da drinnen
VMware, super VMware
Okay
Chat, können wir ausprobieren
Könnte aber sein, also nicht jetzt
könnte aber sein dass der stream instant vorbei ist weil es nicht läuft in
in der vm
ok dann schauen wir mal linux kann so krass aussehen
Also ich bin ja auch ein kleiner Linux-Riser.
Ich habe ja auch mein i3 hier ein bisschen gestylt.
Wobei die Hintergründe eindeutig das Beste sind.
Hier gibt es übrigens die Hintergründe.
Gibt es übrigens auf GitHub.
Warum löscht du in der Adresse immer die...
Das habe ich mir so angewöhnt.
Das macht keinen Sinn.
Gib für jede Tageszeit einen Pepo-Hintergrund.
So.
Also.
Dann schauen wir uns das nochmal an.
Linux kann so krass aussehen.
Das ist bestimmt Hyperland, hä?
Ah, Moment! Mir fehlt noch ein Plugin für den Browser, sehe ich gerade.
Ich brauche noch Dings.
Ähm, Chrome Volume Meter oder wie hieß dieses Ding?
Moment, äh, Volume...
Volume Master.
Volume Master hieß das Ding.
Das da.
Genau, das brauche ich noch.
wichtig.
Guck mal hier, das hier ist
brauche ich nämlich, weil
da kann ich jetzt sagen,
hier ist zu leise oder ist zu laut.
Kann man ein bisschen boosten.
Mit seinem eigenen Fenster-Design,
komplett durchgestylte Taskbar
und File Explorer und so weiter
und so fort. Oder der hier in so
kompletter Retro-Optik
oder dieser hier, der sich nur mit
Magie bedienen lässt.
Jetzt wird es ein bisschen absurd, aber auch
echt verdammt cool. Das Ganze nennt man
Rising und das ist...
Wenn ich sowas immer hier sehe, Leute.
Wisst ihr, was ich dann echt
vermisse?
Kann sich noch jemand an Barrel und Compits
erinnern von früher?
Das war so nice!
Da konntest du damals
wobbly Windows
abfackelnde windows glitzernde windows
der würfel genau 33 d desktop zum
youtube display acht braun
das war kompens war das weiß einfach das war das geilste
er müsste mal wieder ein altes ubuntu installieren mit compas
So sah das aus früher.
Guck mal, von 16 Jahren her.
Hier.
YouTube, please.
Guck mal.
Was man damals alles machen konnte, hä?
Was für Effekte am Start waren.
Habt ihr gesehen?
Das Fenster ist abgefackelt und hat sich aufgebaut.
Ich hoffe, da zeigt noch den Würfel.
Ja, guck mal, Wobbly Windows, Leute
Beste, Wobbly Windows
Brrrr
Ja, hier, die Übersicht
Das war richtig geil, Kompels, damals
Ich hoffe, der zeigt den Würfel auch gleich noch
Ja, genau, hier
Durchscrollen zwischen den einzelnen Programmen
Was du damals alles machen konntest mit
das ist so vergesse magie so irgendwie das gibt's kann ich mal machen auf linux desktop
ich hoffe da zeigt den würfel auch gleich noch
hier der würfel achtung leute würfel guck mal hier konnte sein desktop sehen das du konntest
dein Desktop 3D scrollen
als würfel deine Desktops durch.
Ist das nicht nice?
Ja,
Kompets.
Und das hatten wir schon in Ubuntu,
keine Ahnung, 1204 oder sowas.
Oder 8804.
Ja, in Plasma gibt's
Wobbly Windows und sowas, aber so Sachen wie
brennende Fenster und so gibt es glaube ich nicht mehr.
Das war
extrem nice.
Extremly nice.
Absurd, aber auch echt verdammt cool.
Das Ganze nennt man Rising und das ist quasi
die Kunstform, das eigene Linux
bis ins letzte Detail so hübsch wie
möglich durchzustylen. Und dabei
ist halt alles, was man sich vorstellen kann,
auch irgendwie möglich. Achso, und was das
mit Rise zu tun hat, das erkläre ich später.
Aber kriegt man das auch hin, wenn man kein
Hardcore-Linux-Nerd ist? Also auch ich
als Linux-Nu? Mal schauen.
In diesem Video versuche ich als kompletter Rising-Anfänger meinen Traum-Desktop zu bauen.
Ob das klappt und ob es auch einen Easy-Mode gibt, kommt jetzt. Bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackerinnen, liebe Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen hier. Bye.
Wenn ihr euch für Linux interessiert, seid ihr bestimmt auch viel im Internet unterwegs und
möchtet vielleicht auch mal Dienst. Glaubt, wir checken alle, Linux ist super. Open Source,
schnell, kein Windows-Generve,
wissen wir alle. Sogar PewDiePie weiß das.
Aber ein anderer Aspekt, der mir manchmal
zu oft hinten runterfällt, ist...
Chat, ich habe ja versucht, das PewDiePie-Video zu gucken,
ich habe es nicht ertragen.
Also nicht vom Inhalt her,
ich kann die Art und Weise der Videos,
ich kann mir das nicht geben, das ist unmöglich.
Für mich ist das nicht möglich zu gucken.
...sehr, sehr hübsch aussehen
und wirklich bis ins kleinste Detail
an die eigenen Design- und Funktionsansprüche
angepasst werden. Das Ganze nennt man
Rising. Rising ist die Kunst,
das Linux Betriebssystem richtig geil aussehen zu lassen, ohne dass das irgendwie mit der Leistung
zu tun hat. Also hier geht es eigentlich nur um Optik. Ja, okay, aber was hat die Nummer mit
RISE zu tun? Der Begriff RISING kommt aus der Welt der Autos. RISE steht für Race Inspired
Cosmetic Enhancement, also quasi Karren schnell aussehen zu lassen, ohne dass sie so schnell sind.
Ja, und ich muss sagen, das ist auch das, was mich an Linux immer am meisten gereizt hat. Man
kann sich quasi das eigene Traumbetriebssystem wie so mit Bauklötzchen Stück für Stück selbst
zusammenbauen. Also auch was den Look
angeht. Und im Gegensatz zu Windows oder MacOS
ist das so gut wie alles möglich. Also
wirklich alles. Hier beispielsweise
im r slash Unix-Preddit
findet man richtig krasse Dinger.
Bin ich der Einzige, der das liest?
Schaut mal. Hier hat sich
einfach einer einen Desktop gebaut, der nur
mit magischen Befehlen gesteuert wird. Oder
hier so einer in cuter Pixelart
Rollenspieloptik oder gleich direkt
einfach Minecraft. Ja, okay.
Oder was auch immer das hier sein soll.
Also ihr checkt, es geht wirklich alles.
Und das ist doch irgendwie einfach cool.
Und mich juckt es schon lange in den Fingern, das einfach mal auszuprobieren.
Das war 3D Desktop Cube.
Und das ist doch irgendwie einfach cool.
Achso, das ist genau.
Haben die das tatsächlich auch mittlerweile drin?
Mal auszuprobieren, was ich mir da so zusammenbauen kann.
Da gibt es aber leider ein Problem.
Rising ist, naja, ich sage mal nicht unbedingt einfach.
Und ich benutze Linux zwar ich gerne und finde mich auch grob zurecht, bin aber absolut kein Experte.
Aber fuck it, was soll's, ich probiere es einfach mal.
Ich werde mir ja bestimmt nicht schon wieder mein komplettes Linux kaputt basteln, wie damals, als ich Grub-Disk...
Siehste, das kann mir nicht passieren.
Ich habe Linux hier in meiner VM und da mache ich einfach einen Snapshot, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind.
Ähm...
Ich habe festgestellt, als ich meine VMs kopiert habe, dass ich ein bisschen viel alten Schrott liegen habe.
Ratet mal, wie groß mein VMs-Folder ist.
also nur um euch das jetzt mal zu zeigen meine disk ist hier 250 250 gig und davon ist 187 belegt
so und mein folder ist 680 gigabyte groß
ich muss mal ein bisschen was löschen ja weil man gerade dabei sind ich lösche
hier meine alten snapshots danach guck mal wie groß es dann ist
680 Gig. Ich verwende davon ja eigentlich nur diese eine VM regelmäßig. Oh, das dauert jetzt,
Leute. Wobei, das kann ja jetzt schön im Hintergrund laufen. Wir gucken einfach das
Video weiter. Hübscher machen wollte, oder? Oder? Bisschen leise, oder? Ich würde hier mal zwei
Ansätze fürs Rising unterscheiden. Einen einfacheren Ansatz mit kompletten Desktop-Environments und einen
deutlich schwereren komplett von scratch nur mit window manager ich zeige euch hier mal was ich
jeweils damit erreichen konnte und ja das wird jetzt hier kein mini kleinteiliges tutorial wie
ich was gemacht habe das wird sich je nach geschmack und distribution und so in jedem
case komplett unterscheiden ich nehme euch jetzt einfach mal mit wie ich vorgegangen bin und wie
leicht oder schwer das für mich war als rising noob und apropos distribution ich benutze hier
cache os das passiert auf arch ist schön schnell und ja gefällt mir einfach da hatten wir auch
schon mal ein komplettes video darüber gemacht gerne mal auschecken im prinzip ist es aber ein
das wollte ich auch ausprobieren auf meinem mini pc hier mit euch zusammen
einfach nur dass man es mal gesehen hat benutzen werde ich danach wahrscheinlich nicht weil ich
nicht wissen was ich damit machen soll aber ausprobieren wollte ich mal das muss bekannt
noch mal aufschreiben schreibt man das so esch ios
Egal welche Distro ihr benutzt, es gibt immer Möglichkeiten euren Desktop zu ricen.
Also neben Arch auch auf Ubuntu, Debian, Fedora, Justin Bieber OS usw.
Okay, beim letzten vielleicht nicht.
Was wichtig sein könnte ist euer Display-Server-Protokoll.
Also ob bei euch Wayland oder X11 läuft.
Super grob gesagt sind das beides Protokolle, die definieren wie Fenster und Anwendungen
dargestellt werden und je nachdem braucht ihr dann z.B. die richtige Version vom Window-Manager.
Ach ja, wir hatten auch euch mal nach euren gereisten Desktops gefragt und da sind echt
ein paar coole Einsendungen gekommen.
Hier beispielsweise der Desktop von Florian in KDE gebaut mit Wallpaper Engine oder dieser
hier mit echt coolem Fensterdesign von Matthias in Hyperland oder dieser hier von Anton,
der hier von Michael und dieser von Celina.
Ja, die sehen schon echt gut aus.
Mal schauen, ob das bei mir auch so schön wird.
So, also wie geht man da vor?
Also man kann entweder ein komplettes Desktop Environment nehmen und quasi so umbauen, wie
einem gefällt oder man macht wirklich alles von scratch mit einem window manager aber was ist das
beides überhaupt und wie unterscheiden die sich also ein desktop environment ist eine sammlung
von tools die eine komplette benutzeroberfläche bilden mit der man das betriebssystem bedienen
kann leider sacken alle desktop environments unter linux jetzt werde ich mich wahrscheinlich
sowohl bei den knorr leuten als auch bei den kde benutzern unbeliebt machen aber mir gefällt keine
desktop umgebung unter linux und das sage ich als linux fanboy das einzige was ich ertrage
ist i3. Das ist ja keine richtige Desktop-Umgebung. Hyperland würde ich wahrscheinlich auch ertragen,
allerdings lässt es sich nicht mich ertragen, weil es nicht funktioniert in der VM. So was wie der
Fenster- und File-Manager, das Startmenü, die Taskleiste, das Screenshot-Tool und so weiter.
Also quasi alles, was man so braucht. XFCE ist auch ganz nice. Also wenn ich nicht i3 verwenden
könnte und ich müsste, ich wäre
dazu gezwungen, irgendwas Klassischeres
zu verwenden, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich auch XFCE
benutzen.
Window Manager steuert
nur die Fans da und man muss wirklich
alles weitere manuell dazu nutzen.
Ich hatte früher, zu Zeiten, wo
ich noch nicht gecheckt habe, dass
Tiling Window Manager eigentlich
POC sind, hatte ich
Openbox und Fluxbox. Kennt das jemand?
Openbox? Openbox? Linux?
Das war auch so ein
richtig minimalistisches Ding.
wo du eigentlich nichts hattest,
außer einen Desktop, wo du rechts klicken konntest drauf.
Ja, genau, so.
Man sieht es jetzt hier nicht wirklich.
Openbox.
Genau, du hattest eigentlich nur ein Rechtsklick-Menü auf dem Desktop,
um Sachen zu starten.
Der Rest war einfach Floating Windows ohne irgendwas.
Das hatte ich früher immer.
Openbox, Luxbox.
Aber danach
habe ich dann irgendwann gesagt, ey, weißt du was?
Tiling Window Manager, beste.
Ja, und das
ist natürlich deutlich aufwendiger.
Aber man hat dadurch auch viel mehr Freiheiten, wie man
sich seinen Desktop zusammenbauen kann.
Und bei Window Managern wird es auch richtig abgefahren,
aber da kommen wir später noch zu. Bei Desktop
Environments ist man da nicht so frei,
man kann aber auch schon einiges machen.
Wenn man CacheOS installiert, hat man
verschiedene Desktop Environments und
Window Manager zur Auswahl. Als ich das
damals installiert hatte, habe ich einfach KDE
genommen, weil das kenne ich halt schon.
Das sieht out of the box erstmal relativ
basic aus. Also Taskleiste
hier unten mit Startmenü und Fenstern,
die ähnlich aussehen wie bei Windows, finde ich.
Aber hier in KDE kann man auch schon eine
Menge reißen. Mit Rechtsklick auf die
Taskleiste unter Panel Configuration
kann man hier quasi alles verschieben,
Animationen ändern und neue
Widgets oder komplette Panel-Linien. Die Blume ist
von Ikea. Also mit ein paar Klicks kann ich mir den
Das ist ... Der hat quasi auch ...
Der hat ReLive gereist.
Der Ikea-Rice.
... wie bei Windows 11 hier in die Mitte holen.
Oder hier oben eine Menüleiste ...
Warum will man den Button in der Mitte? Nein, please!
... OS einfügen. Interessant wird es ...
Chat, gibt's jemanden von euch,
der unter Windows 11 den Button in der Mitte lässt?
Also so hier.
So.
Ja.
Und warum?
Also warum willst du den in der Mitte haben und nicht links?
Also ich sag euch mal den Vorteil von links.
Links ist, du kannst die...
Achso, du musst sonst das Auge zu weit bewegen, oder wie?
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Ja, okay, das leuchtet ein.
Warum ich das unten links habe, ist ganz einfach.
du kannst deine Maus einfach nach unten links schieben
und bist immer, wenn du die Maus
unten links auf Anschlag schiebst, immer auf dem Startbutton.
Ja, man kann natürlich auch den Knopf drücken,
aber wenn man wirklich mal ist, ich finde das einfach
praktischer.
Ah ja, naja. Hätte ich das gar nicht gedacht.
Ich hätte gedacht, alle wollen das
immer links haben.
Aber anscheinend nicht.
unter Einstellung Colors and Themes.
Hier kann man sich nämlich über die... Ganz ehrlich,
das interessiert mich gar nicht so sehr.
Window Manager
juckt mich viel. Egal, wir gucken es trotzdem.
New Button, Community gebaute
Themes runterladen. Ja, und dann kommt auch
dieser Sicherheitshinweis, dass die ausführbaren
Code enthalten könnten, der nicht getestet
wurde. Die beliebtesten haben hier aber teilweise
über eine Million Downloads und das
sollte schon irgendwie legitim sein. Bei Sachen,
die sich keiner runtergeladen hat und die einem
komisch vorkommen, würde ich aber ein bisschen vorsichtig
sein. Aber auf jeden Fall kann man sich genauso
auch neue Icons, Farbschema
und Lockscreens runterladen. Und so
kann man sich in der Theorie mit 2-3
Klicks den Desktop...
Chat, wir müssten glaube ich echt mal
just for fun wieder KDE ausprobieren.
KDE hat bei mir
halt so
kein gutes Standing gehabt
von früher. Ich fand das einfach
immer super überladen und 30
Milliarden Optionen und nix hast du
irgendwie gefunden und das war
halt KDE-Feeling.
Aber ich glaube, mittlerweile
ist KDE...
Bei welcher Version sind wir da jetzt eigentlich gerade?
Wobei, gibt es überhaupt noch
KDE-Versionen oder heißt das einfach nur noch KDE-Plasma?
Plasma 6?
Ich glaube,
das müssen wir echt mal ausprobieren.
Das müssen wir, glaube ich, mal ausprobieren.
Top, schon. Komplett
umbauen. Also eigentlich
relativ easy. Falls man noch tiefer reingehen
will, kann man sich auch den Quantum Manager
runterladen. Der bietet dann noch verbesserte
Transparenz bei Fenstern und so
Kram. Unter System Settings, Window
Management, Desktop Effects, lassen
sich auch noch ein paar Animationen einstellen.
Ah, Wobbly
Window. Endlich.
Das allerwichtigste
Feature ist back.
Diese wabbelnden Fenster hier.
Also,
wenn ich noch einen Window
Manager verwenden würde, der wirklich
Window managt,
ja,
dann bräuchte ich unbedingt
Wobbly Windows.
Ich meine, man kann, man kann Window,
ups.
Okay.
Äh, hallo?
Äh...
Chat, was ist mit meiner
VM los
gerade?
Was ist da?
Was ist da kaputt?
Okay, wisst ihr was?
Reset
Was nutzt du denn jetzt eigentlich?
Das ist Arch mit I3
Snapshot gerade fertig
Ne, ich hab Snapshots gelöscht
Und das Löschen der Snapshots war fertig
Du hast auf GitHub übrigens auch meine .files
Zwar nicht so top aktuell, aber halbwegs aktuell
Mit I3, genau
Okay, jetzt haben wir rebooted, jetzt funzt es wieder
Auch gut
Ja, also ich mein, man kann hier schon
Windows managen
Ja, also wenn ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel sage
zack, kommen wir Chrome auf.
Gehen wir mal hier, zack,
können wir in Windows wechseln.
Aber das macht man ja normalerweise nicht.
Gehen tut das,
dass man hier ein Window hat.
So, und
wenn ich Windows
verwenden würde, öfters, also
Windows, dann
eindeutig mit
Wobbly Windows.
Warte mal.
Ich benutze ja
hier
ICOM
als so Composite Manager
und
gibt es dafür Wobbly Windows?
Ne.
Gibt es anscheinend
Gibt es anscheinend nicht
Es gibt kein Wobbly Windows
Naja, egal
Gucken wir das Video weiter
Achso, ich muss ja erstmal den Taskmanager aufmachen
Zack
Was ist das für ein
Das ist Arch mit I3
By the way, ich use Arch.
By the way.
Mit I3.
Und der Grund, warum es jetzt nicht
Wayland, Hyperland,
Arch ist, liegt einfach daran,
dass hier läuft in der 4M, guck,
und Wayland
in der 4M funzt nicht.
Richtig.
Guck mal, das Video fertig.
Warply Windows, bester,
bester Effekt.
einfach so zerbröckeln. Und hier gibt es auch
Community-gebastelte Sachen, die man sich runterladen
kann, wie zum Beispiel diesen Glitch-Effekt.
Ein weiteres sehr beliebtes Desktop-Environment
ist GNOME. GNOME sieht optisch
ein bisschen mehr aus wie macOS und hat echt
smoothe Animationen, also das gefällt mir
out of the box eigentlich schon echt gut. Ja, und in
GNOME habe ich dann auch meinen ersten richtigen
Rising-Versuch gestartet. Woher kommt dieses Arch,
by the way? Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das
aufgekommen ist.
Das kommt halt daher, dass die Art, dass
Artstellungs-User immer erzählen müssen, dass
die Arch-Lilux verwenden. Wir fragen
mal hier, Arch
by the way, ob es dazu eine Erklärung
gibt.
Know your
meme, by the way, I use Arch.
Wo kommt das her?
Origin.
Arch-Lilux.
Ich use Arch-Lilux.
Okay, wo kommt das her?
An early example was uploaded to twitter
Also anscheinend kommt das
The exact origin of the phrase is unknown
Ja
Man weiß nicht, wo es herkommt
Würdest du dir Arch
in Silly Native, wenn du nichts mehr zocken würdest
Ähm
Also es gibt ja noch ein paar andere Sachen, außer Spielen, was ich unter Windows mache.
Zum Beispiel Videos, wenn ich denn Videos mache, ich weiß, keck, wait, ja, aber das läuft nur unter Windows.
Wobei ich da tatsächlich mir angucken wollte, beispielsweise mal sowas wie DaVinci Resolve,
mir anzugucken, was auch unter Linux läuft.
Und es gibt bestimmt mittlerweile auch ein paar ganz brauchbare Bildbearbeitungsprogramme, wo ich Thumbnails erstellen kann unter Linux.
Also wenn ich gar nichts mehr spielen würde, dann glaube ich, ist die Chance relativ hoch, dass ich tatsächlich komplett auf Linux unterwegs wäre.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es für mich allerdings ausgeschlossen, dass ich gar nichts mehr spiele.
Also das wird nicht vorkommen.
Man muss aber sagen, gerade auf Sachen wie CacheOS zum Beispiel, also das ist jetzt hörend sagen, ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert, muss das mit Spielen auch ziemlich gut funktionieren.
Das einzige, was nicht funktioniert und das ist auch das, was mich davon abhält, Linux zu verwenden oder ein großer Punkt, der mich davon abhält, Linux zu verwenden, ist Spiele mit Anti-Cheat, weil da hat man komplett gelitten.
Also wer sowas wie beispielsweise Rainbow Six spielen will oder das neue Battlefield, der hat gelitten.
Der neue Steam Controller.
Steam Controller. Gab's da einen neuen?
Der sieht immer noch aus wie der alte, oder?
Ist das der neue?
Der alte sah doch auch so ähnlich aus, oder?
Was ist denn das da?
Ist das ein Touchfeld, oder?
Aha.
Also ich benutze, wenn ich mit dem Controller spiele,
einfach einen Xbox-Controller
per USB
und einen ganz alten übrigens
noch, einen Xbox 360-Controller,
weil ich
immer noch finde, der Xbox 360-Controller
ist angenehmer
als der Xbox One-Controller
oder die neueren.
Und
damit bin ich eigentlich happy.
Hast du was? Was für ein Xenon-Wired-Controller?
Was für ein Ding?
Ne.
Ich habe einen Xbox 360-Controller
mit USB.
Ich habe aber einen offiziellen Xbox 360-Controller.
Noch.
Also stabiler kann ich nachvollziehen.
Bei Arch gab es ja in den letzten Jahren
über mal ein paar kleine Problemchen.
Zum Beispiel das, wo der Boot...
Erinnert sich noch einer dran, wo der Bootloader
sich zerschossen hat? Oder war das eine
Manjaro-Geschichte?
Da gab es doch hier, wo Krab kaputt gegangen ist.
Unter Arch bei einem Update.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen
muss man wirklich sagen,
das ist erstaunlich stable.
Für das, dass man im 15-Minuten-Takt Paket-Updates bekommt.
Okay, im halben Stunden-Takt vielleicht Paket-Updates bekommt.
Ist das erstaunlich stable.
Ich kann mich jetzt nicht daran erinnern, weil ich das letzte Mal ein nicht-bootbares Arch-Dilux hatte.
Ist aber auch kein Problem, weil Arch, by the way, ich mache einfach einen Snapshot vorher.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das Video mal fertig ist.
... mehrere Desktop-Environments und Window-Manager parallel installieren.
Die kann man dann hier im Login-Screen wechseln.
Die bringen aber auch alle eigene Probleme und Konfigurationen mit, die sich ins Gehege kommen könnten.
Naja, ich habe es jetzt trotzdem einfach mal gemacht.
Gnome ist auch super einfach installiert.
Einfach hier unter Arch, sudo pacman-s gnome eintippen und ein paar Mal bestätigen.
Und dann wird Gnome mit allen dazugehörigen Paketen und Programmen installiert.
Dann kann ich mich hier bei KDE einfach ausloggen, Gnome auswählen und wieder einloggen.
Und ja, GNOME sieht out of the box meiner Meinung nach deutlich cooler aus als KDE und ist dazu noch sehr durchdacht in seiner Bedienung.
Dafür kannst du in GNOME gar nicht so viel einstellen, ne?
Früher hat man immer noch GNOME Tweaks dafür gebraucht, um ein paar Basics Sachen einzustellen.
Das ist aber auch so ein bisschen die Philosophie hinter GNOME.
Dock hier unten und zu cleanem Desktop-Management und so weiter.
Aber man kann in GNOME auch deutlich weniger einstellen als in KDE, zumindest erstmal so per Default.
Aber es gibt Community Extensions, mit denen man das Environment anpassen kann.
Über GNOME Software kann man sich den Extension Manager runterladen und die dann easy installieren.
Beispielsweise sowas wie Blur My Shell.
Dadurch sieht zum Beispiel die Menüleiste hier oben nochmal transparenter aus.
Und falls es einen nervt, dass das Dock hier unten immer erst dann zu sehen ist, wenn man Option bzw. Alt gedrückt hat,
kann man sich das mit der Extension Dash to Dock dauerhaft anzeigen lassen.
Oder gleich so eine Taskleiste wie bei KDE mit Dash-to-Panel einblenden.
Okay, also bei meinem ersten Versuch, Gnome mal rudimentär zu reißen, ist das hier rausgekommen.
Mit Icons, Farben, Fenster und Dock-Design, was ich alles aufs Wallpaper abgestimmt habe.
Ich habe versucht, so eine holzige Optik zu bauen und ich muss sagen, gefällt mir eigentlich ganz okay.
Ich glaube, wenn man wirklich was krass customizen will, ist Gnome nicht das Richtige.
KDE hat auf jeden Fall deutlich mehr Optionen
oder aber man geht gleich in die
vollen und wenn man sich mal
Unix-Porn anguckt, da ist ja
alles voller Hyperland-Installationen
Alles Geschmackssache, ne? Die Leiste hier oben
habe ich noch um ein paar Funktionen wie diesen Spotify
Player oder diese Netzwerkanzeige erweitert
Ach ja, und das hier kann ich auch
Das ist zwar mega unnötig, aber
Ja, witzig halt
Wie ohne beste Desktop-Cube
Wie ich das gemacht habe, zeige ich euch
hier mal im Schnelldurchlauf, weil das sonst eine Ewigkeit
dauern würde. Aber keine Sorge, das war alles
gar nicht mal so kompliziert. Also erstmal
ein Wallpaper finden, was mir gefällt
und dann einstellen. Dann Gnome Tweaks
runterladen, das ist so ein Programm, mit dem man
mehr Zeug... Das musste man früher auch schon
immer installieren, wenn man da ein bisschen
customizen wollte bei Gnome.
...Gnome anpassen kann und auch
Themes einstellen kann. Dann im
Extensions Manager User Themes runterladen.
Damit lassen sich, ja,
User Themes installieren. Auf
gnome-look.com unter
gnome shell themes gibt es einige zum download die shell themes verändern unter anderem das doc und
die menüleiste hier oben da eins aussuchen ich habe mich hier für ever forest entschieden weil
das mit der weidigen optik zum wallpaper passt runterladen und in den themes ordner unter home
euer benutzername local share extrahieren falls es den ordner nicht gibt einfach einen erstellen
dann unter extensions in die user themes einstellung und das team auswählen damit sich
auch die Fensteroptik verändert.
Ich finde, sobald man anfängt
Gnome zu customizen, dann fühlt sich das
irgendwie so an, als arbeitet man
gegen Gnome selber.
Das fühlt sich dann alles so halboffiziell
an. Das ist unter KDE halt viel
nicer. Das war aber
früher auch schon so. Also KDE war damals
ja auch schon bekannt für 30 Milliarden Optionen.
Also auch nur noch vor Plasma.
Noch das Everforest GTK
Theme runterladen. GTK steht für
Graphical Toolkit und ist eine
widget toolkit bibliothek womit grafische oberflächen erstellt werden unterladen und
dann den assets ordner und gtk css in home slash user slash config gtk 4.0 kopieren jetzt hätte
ich gern noch passende icons dafür wieder auf no minus lux punkt kommen ein icon paket aussuchen
und runterladen ich fand das hier ganz gut also das geht das ging doch bei kde auf jeden fall
schon eiser icons extrahieren dann bei gnome tweaks unter appearance auswählen fertig weil
ich das Dock unten irgendwie ein bisschen lame fand, habe ich mir noch Dash to Dock Animated
als Extension installiert. Damit kann man auch nochmal komplett alles am Dock verändern, wie
beispielsweise eine Animation beim Hoveren und Öffnen einstellen, Icongröße, Hintergrund, Blur,
Abstände und diese weißen Pünktchen einstellen, die anzeigen, ob ein Programm läuft oder nicht.
Ganz cool. Ja und es hört einfach nicht auf. Wenn man damit einmal angefangen hat,
kommt man in so einen Sog, aus dem man auch irgendwie nicht mehr richtig rauskommt. Ich
habe dann noch ein passendes Theme für Firefox installiert, nach alternativen Spotify,
kleines geguckt und so weiter das war jetzt aber quasi noch der easy mode richtig ans eingemachte
geht es mit window manager bei dem gegensatz zum desktop in weihmann jetzt geht's los ja wirklich
nur die fenster dabei also kein start menü keine taskleiste gar nichts window manager gibt es in
verschiedenen varianten es gibt stacking window manager da hat man so normale fenster die sich
überlappen also wie bei windows und mac os auch und teiling window man beste da werden die fenster
automatisch arrangiert.
Es überlappt sich erstmal nichts.
Ich habe mich hier für Hyperland entschieden.
Da werden die Fenster automatisch...
Das brauche ich auch.
Mein, mein, äh...
Fetch sieht total
lame aus dagegen.
Ich will auch so einen cute...
Fetch.
...automatisch arrangiert und es
überlappt sich erstmal nichts.
Ich habe mich hier für Hyperland entschieden, weil ich
den sehr oft im Unix-Reddit gesehen habe.
NeoFetch ist old.
Ich verwende auch gar nicht NeoFetch.
Der Chat wieder.
Ich verwende FastFetch.
Gibt's CuteFetch?
Das gibt's wirklich?
Das ist aber bestimmt nicht das, was man haben will.
Meiner Meinung nach kamen da irgendwie auch die
coolsten Desktops bei rum. Allerdings das als
Disclaimer, der Hyperland Hauptprogrammierer
ist bereits mehrfach mit sehr toxischem
Verhalten aufgefallen, weshalb das
freedesktop.org Projekt Hyperland
ausgeschlossen hat. Also nur
zur Info. Echt? Ist er? Das hat er
getrieben. Ich habe mich leider auch erst
rausgefunden, nachdem ich hier schon alles zusammengebastelt
hatte. Beim nächsten Mal würde ich wahrscheinlich einen anderen
Window Manager wählen. Und ja, da habe ich jetzt
echt einige Stunden investiert, hunderte
Tutorials und Reddit-Beiträge angeglotzt,
um mir meinen super krassen
Cutting-Edge durchdesignten Desktop
zu bauen. Also, aufgepasst,
so sieht der aus.
Na gut, das ist leider gar nicht
mal so hübsch geworden. Ja, das stimmt.
Naja, aber auch wenn es nicht danach aussieht,
hier steckt echt eine Menge Arbeit drin und
ist es fast alles custom von mir bearbeitet.
Besser habe ich es aber mit der Zeit, die mir zur Verfügung stand,
nicht hinbekommen.
Und ey, wenn man das erste Mal Hyperland öffnet,
sieht die Nummer so aus.
Also da finde ich meins schon zumindest ein bisschen hübscher, sage ich mal.
Hyperland-Chan am Start.
Ich muss aber sagen, das wird nicht so bleiben
und ich werde auf jeden Fall daran weiter basteln.
Weil auch wenn das kompliziert und fummelig ist,
macht das auch echt total Spaß.
Und man lernt auch echt eine Menge.
Und die Bedienung von so Tiling-Window-Managern
ist auch was komplett anderes als beispielsweise bei macOS oder so.
Hier wird nämlich jedes Fenster automatisch platziert und alles sitzt so nebeneinander.
Mit verschiedenen Hotkeys kann man dann neue Fenster öffnen, Workspaces erstellen und zwischen denen hin und her wechseln.
Ist erstmal ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Es ist sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig. Ich habe bestimmt ein halbes Jahr gebraucht, bis ich so richtig drinne hatte.
Also die Tiling-with-no-Manager-Geschichte.
Man ist das so gewöhnt, dass wenn man beispielsweise einen Browser aufhat und einen Terminal,
dass man dann quasi switcht zwischen dem Fenster und dem anderen Fenster.
also man ist es halt so gewöhnt, so dass man hier
ein Fenster hat, da, dann anklickt, dann hier rum.
Das ist halt gar nicht. Man muss sich da an
Desktop-Switchen gewöhnen.
Bei Tiling Window Manager.
Oder halt, man hat mehrere Fenster gleichzeitig
auf. Das ich hab bestimmt ein halbes
Jahr für gebraucht, bis ich mich richtig dran gewöhnt hab.
Aber seitdem ist das komplett in Fleisch
und Blut übergegangen und ich hätt am liebsten
überall nur noch Tiling Window Manager.
Aber wenn man den Dreh einmal raus hat,
dann macht das schon irgendwie Spaß.
Und falls ihr mir nicht glaubt, dass das wirklich viel Arbeit war, ich gehe jetzt mal ganz grob durch, was ich hier gemacht habe.
Erstmal habe ich Hyperland installiert. Das geht easy.
Einfach hier unter Arch mit sudo pacman-s hyperland.
Dann ausloggen, hier im Login-Screen auf Hyperland stellen und wieder einloggen.
Und dann sieht man erstmal wirklich gar nichts.
Mit Option Q kann ich mir hier aber ein Terminal-Fenster öffnen oder mit Option E den File-Manager.
Naja, aber erstmal in die Hyperland-Config-Datei und da sowas wie die Bildschirmskalender...
Du kannst dir das mit Multiscreen schwer vorstellen. Warum?
Du kannst unter
I3, kannst du verschiedene
Desktops auf verschiedenen Bildschirmen haben.
Also du könntest zum Beispiel sagen, dass du deinen Browser
immer auf dem linken Bildschirm haben willst, dann wird
der erste Desktop hier gar nicht angezeigt werden.
Und wenn du dann auf den ersten Desktop switchst,
dann geht der auf den anderen Bildschirm.
Das geht eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Multi-Bildschirm.
Ich hatte das auf der Arbeit, jahrelang.
Verhalten.
So anpassen, dass nicht alles
komisch aussieht. Dann habe ich mir über das Terminal einen App Launcher installiert. Woffi
ist wohl sehr beliebt und anpassbar, deswegen habe ich den genommen. Wenn der läuft, kann man
Option R drücken und darüber Programme starten. Damit man solche Sachen nicht nach jedem Restart
manuell übers Terminal starten muss, muss man in der Hyperlens-Punktrichtung Programme eintragen,
die beim Starten geöffnet werden sollen. Um einen anderen Hintergrund einzustellen,
habe ich mir das Programm Hyper Paper runtergeladen. Da kann man in der Config eine Bilddatei als
Hintergrund festlegen. Zusätzlich habe ich mir noch einen Screenshot Tool installiert. Um das
benutzen zu können, habe ich dann in der Hyperland Config erstmal die Tastenbelegung eingetragen,
also alles per Text. Weil das ist einfach alles nicht voreingestellt oder ja, das muss man alles
selber machen. Was ich noch wichtig finde, ist eine Menüleiste wie diese hier. Dafür habe ich
mir das beliebte Tool Waiver installiert. Und das sieht out of the box erstmal richtig, naja,
Ja, ässlich aus.
Hierfür muss man dann wieder die Config anfassen.
Finde so schlimm, sieht es gerade aus.
Im Internet findet man aber auch ein paar Vorgefertigte, die man sich kopieren kann.
Ich habe mir da eins ausgesucht und dann versucht, es so ein bisschen 3003 mäßig anzupassen.
Ja, und alles wieder in der Config.
Für Farben braucht man dann den Hexacode, aber auch manchmal den RGBA-Code.
Und das muss man dann alles einzeln händisch hier hin und her kopieren.
Also beispielsweise für das Arch-Logo hier links oben oder diese Workspace-Anzeige hier in der Mitte.
Muss man halt alles in der Config händisch machen.
Und das dauert.
Dann habe ich noch die Transparenz angepasst und ja, sieht doch ein bisschen nach 3003 aus, oder?
Also, finde ich.
Und so läuft das halt die ganze Zeit ab.
Programme runterladen, die man braucht und dann die sogenannten .files bearbeiten.
Das sind versteckte Konfigurationsdateien, wie beispielsweise die Hyperland-Config.
Und dann kann man sich entweder bestehende Sachen kopieren oder...
Wayland war doch der Windows-Server von Hyperland, oder habe ich das falsch in Erinnerung gebracht, der Chat?
Ja, wobei da die Wayland-Fans wahrscheinlich sagen würden, dass das nicht stimmt, weil
Wayland kein Display-Server oder Windows-Server ist, sondern eigentlich nur eine Protokoll-Spezifikation,
die jeder Window-Manager selbst implementieren muss.
Deswegen hast du auch das Problem, dass unter einem Window-Manager Sachen funktionieren
können und unter einem anderen nicht.
... halt alles händisch selber anpassen.
Und das ist oft sehr viel CSS-Gefrickel und ja, sehr viel Arbeit.
Ich habe mir dann auf jeden Fall noch mein Terminal ein bisschen aufgehübscht und noch die Ränder von den Fenstern aufs...
Deswegen habe ich auch seit zwei Jahren kaum noch was gemacht an meiner Linux-Kiste.
Das Ding ist einfach so eingerichtet, wie ich es haben will.
Und deswegen fasse ich da nichts mehr großartig an.
Das funzt einfach und sieht auch, finde ich, ganz gut aus, oder?
Oh man, natürlich beste Hintergründe.
Kannst dich eigentlich nicht beschweren.
Sieht thematisch alles ähnlich aus.
Die Anzeige und so.
Die Leiste hier oben ist jetzt sicherlich nicht die hübscheste.
Aber es zeigt alles an, was man braucht.
Und das aller nicestste, also was wirklich richtig, richtig nice ist,
was ich aber nie verwende, weil ich selbst programmiert habe damals für die Leiste,
ist dieser Timer hier oben.
Guck.
Oh man.
Timer starten kann und wenn der Timer
äh
guck mal
wenn der Timer
abläuft, dann
ploppt es auf und sagt, dass der
Timer abgelaufen ist.
Ja.
So sieht es aus.
Haben wir
selbst broggert im
Stream.
Benutze ich aber so gut wie nie.
Und die CPU-Auslastung-Anzeige finde ich ganz gut.
Ich mache mal ein bisschen CPU-Last.
Guck, das hier ist ein Balken für jeden CPU-Kern.
Da sieht man auf einen Blick gleich, ob der Rechner großartig ausgelastet ist oder nicht.
Das haben wir aber nicht selbst programmiert, das ist dabei.
Das ist standardmäßig hier dabei.
Video fertig kommen.
3003 grün angepasst und so Kleinigkeiten gemacht.
Es gibt wohl auch Installationssoftware, die automatisch DotFiles installieren kann.
Also da sucht man sich die Themes aus und dann wird alles installiert und eingestellt.
Aber ich habe das jetzt wirklich mal versucht, soweit es geht, selbst zu bauen.
Das ist für mich ja auch irgendwie der Sinn dahinter.
Also man baut sich seinen eigenen Traum-Desktop zusammen.
Aber ja, wenn man da keinen Bock drauf hat, dann kann man das mal ausprobieren oder gleich den Weg mit KDE oder GNOME gehen.
Macht auch Spaß und ist deutlich einfacher.
Also ihr merkt, dass es...
Und auch deutlich benutzbarer von Anfang an.
Alles echt dicht ohne.
Macht aber, wie gesagt, auch eine Menge Spaß.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall so okay zufrieden mit meinem Ergebnis, sage ich mal.
Aber falls ihr das besser könnt, schickt uns doch gerne mal einen Screenshot an 3003.ct.de.
Dann können wir den vielleicht im Newsletter ausstellen.
Naja, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Abonnieren nicht vergessen und tschüss.
See you.
Gucken wir uns denn als nächstes an.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich das aufgemacht habe.
Ich weiß nicht.
Software Update
Software Update deletes everything
all in 10 days.
Schnell-Imbiss-Besitzer.
ESL?
Was, ESL?
Wolltest du das Kongress-Video schauen?
Ja, aber das ist jetzt
das ist ein 32 minuten video das ist zu lang
wir gucken jetzt lohnt sich das der schnell im bis besitzer
ich glaube das ist zur abwechslung mal wieder einer hierbei bei lohnt sich das
der wirklich den ganzen tag von neun bis abends am schaffen ist
Den gönne ich die Kohle auch immer.
Vor allem musst du dich den ganzen Tag mit irgendwelchen nervigen Kunden auseinandersetzen.
Klingt ein bisschen wie Peter vom Microsoft Support.
Ist laut genug, oder?
Moin, mein Name ist Rade Mandal.
Ich bin 34 Jahre alt und betreibe zwei Kumpierläden in Oldenburg.
Moin, der ist Rade.
Moin mein Lieber. Wie geht's dir?
Warum haben wir eigentlich einen Untertitel?
Warum ist das ein Untertitel? Das macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Warum sind da Untertitel an?
Heute wieder ein Großeinkauf, oder?
Ja, es braucht einiges an Gemüse und so weiter.
Wie viel Uhr war das jetzt? Ich habe jetzt gar nicht aufgepasst, wie viel Uhr ist da aufgestanden?
Ach, 8 Uhr, 8.59 Uhr, okay.
Vegane Mayonnaise, um unsere vegane Rote-Bete-Mayo-Soße zu machen.
Wobei ich sehe, dass die eine große Packung haben und ich würde mal dann den nehmen.
Was besteht denn vegane Mayonnaise?
Mayonnaise ist doch, was ist denn das?
Eier und Senf, oder?
Und Öl?
Eier, Senf, irgendwie so?
Öl, ach Eier und Öl, nicht Senf.
Wie macht man das denn dann vegan?
Schönen Tag auch, danke schön.
Schauen wir mal, was auf uns wartet.
Mit dem Wetter hier sieht es nicht so gut aus heute.
Aber ein paar Kunden kommen auf jeden Fall.
Nach dem Einkaufen bringe ich meine ganze Ware an beide meine Läden.
Dann fange ich mit meiner Vorbereitung für den Tag an.
Wir haben dafür eine Stunde ausgedacht.
Und das reicht uns dann auch völlig.
Moin!
Ich lege es dir kurz hier.
Hoffentlich keine Tossmusik wieder in dem Beitrag.
Kommt jemand noch mit dir mittags?
Nee, dann bin ich später noch hier.
Ich glaube, heute wird es ein bisschen voller sein.
Und daher habe ich mir jetzt entschieden, dass wir eine Unterstützung holen.
Hallo Anupa, hi. Kannst du starten, neu laden?
Ich glaube, da wird jeder Tag anders laufen als gedacht.
Ich glaube, es ist echt stressig, sowas.
Du kannst im alten Laden dann arbeiten.
Kannst du dann hier am Bahnhofsplatz kommen?
Ja, gerne.
Okay, vielen Dank. Bis gleich, tschüss.
Kumpir ist eine große Ofenkartoffel, die wird mit Soße und...
Ich habe gelernt, das habe ich bei einem indischen Laden,
dass Alu Mutter heißt auf Indisch glaube ich Kartoffeln mit Erbsen.
Alu Mutter.
Der Ofen ist ganz ganz speziell nur für Ofenkartoffeln gedacht.
Heißt auch Kumpierofen.
Ja Alfred, genau, Alu Mutter.
Ganz oben werden die Kartoffeln dann warm bleiben. Der hat uns jetzt über fünf Jahre begleitet und ich hoffe, der schöne Stück kann noch fünf Jahre mitmachen. Der ist ein Herzstück von unserem Laden.
Ist das Toss? Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Der Umsatz könnte zwischen 800 und 1000 Euro für heute liegen.
und Tausender wäre super.
Da freue ich mich dann sehr gut.
Ich hoffe, dass das Wetter mit ist.
Wir hatten auch so einen Ofenkartoffelladen früher
in Frankfurt.
Das war Frankfurt,
das muss ich kurz erzählen.
Das war ein Laden,
mittags konntest du da so Ofenkartoffeln
futtern und nebendran
war
irgendein Massagestudio.
Das war eine ganz
weirde Kombination,
Essen und Massagestudio.
Das Problem war bloß, der Laden war
auf der...
Nicht auf der Kaiserstraße.
Was ist denn dahinter?
Münchner? Ne, Münchnerstraße ist die andere Seite.
Taunusstraße? Kann das sein?
Weiß nicht.
Zumindest auf einem der
ehemaligen Rotlichtstraßen
in Frankfurt, wo es heute kaum noch was gibt.
Zumindest
hat mich das damals schon
immer gewundert. Was ist das für eine Kombination?
also Ofenkartoffel und Massage und so.
Und anscheinend, ja genau, und irgendwann gab es dann da keine Massage mehr.
Und irgendwann habe ich dann den Zettel da hängen sehen, da stand dann da,
Massage nur ohne Happy End.
Also anscheinend sind die Leute in den Laden reingegangen und haben sich gedacht,
okay, wir sind hier auf der Rotlichtstraße, Massage gleich Handbetrieb.
Dabei war das nur ein normaler Massageladen. Das musstest du da hinschreiben.
Dafür gab es ganz gute Ofenkartoffeln.
Einen Laden zu besitzen war immer mein Traum. Ich habe mich seit 2023 im März selbstständig gemacht.
Erster Laden habe ich dann von dem alten Besitzer übernommen.
Der zweite Laden ist gerade drei Wochen alt.
Der ist von Wolfsbiss abends am Schaffen hier.
Ich habe jetzt gerade Anruf bekommen, dass in anderen Laden die vegane Mayonnaise fehlt.
Und deswegen bringe ich sie jetzt gerade mit dem Fahrrad schnell.
Bis gleich!
Toss, toss, toss, toss.
Hi, Prasanti.
Boah, da ist aber was los, hä?
Sehr gut.
Es ist ganz viel los, es muss kurz helfen.
Natürlich kann man das nicht vorhersehen, wie es dann in den beiden Läden dann jetzt
geht.
Welche Zahlen von Kunden werden wir erwarten?
Okay, also das ist ein quasi ein Ofenkartoffelladen.
Boah, schon krass, oder?
Dass man mittlerweile 11 Euro für eine Ofenkartoffel bezahlt?
Da kann er ja nichts für, aber die Preise sind mittlerweile schon echt heftig.
Der zweite Laden bedeutet für mich sehr, sehr viel, weil ich diesen Laden nach meinem
Geschmack gestaltet habe, wie ich das gewünscht habe.
Und daher, das ist auf jeden Fall mein Favoritprojekt.
War alles gut bei euch?
Bin sofort bei euch, ja.
Ich habe in diesem Laden jetzt schon 60.000 Euro investiert.
Also ich glaube ich würde die Ofenkartoffeln dem Döner vorziehen, Chat.
Ich hatte schon so oft Verdauungsprobleme nach Dönern.
Ich esse eigentlich nur noch bei einem Laden, esse ich Döner.
Rechnungen, die ich jederzeit erwarte.
Dann muss ich gucken, was da rauskommt.
Ich hoffe, es ist keine große, böse Überraschung.
Heute erwarte ich für diesen Laden einen Umsatz zwischen 350 und 450 Euro.
Danke schön.
Was ist deine Meinung zu Battlefield 6? Ich habe noch nicht gespielt.
Ich kann jetzt auch erst spielen, weil ich mal Windows neu installiert habe.
Super, vielen Dank. Dann 14 Euro mag das dann bitte.
Ich mag dir einen Mittagstil, das kostet dann 13 Euro.
Danke.
Unerwartete Zahlen von Kunden hier im neuen Laden, das kennen wir nicht so.
Elfero, mach das bitte mit Karte.
Gerne.
Ich komme aus Nepal, aus dem Süden von Nepal, an der Grenze zu Indien, aus einem kleinen Dorf.
Ich habe Eltern in Nepal, meine beiden Brüder und meine beiden Schwestern, die leben dann immer noch in Nepal.
11. August 2011 bin ich als Student nach Deutschland gekommen.
Ich hatte ein Studienvisum und sehr wenig Geld.
Ich glaube, das war 1.000...
Aber cool, wie er das auf die Reihe gekriegt hat.
115 Euro oder 1.117 Euro ungefähr.
Jetzt ist der Stabmixer kaputt gegangen.
Dann mache ich es jetzt schnell, damit es für heute reicht.
Dann gebe ich den Stabmixer, damit sie dort mitnehmen kann.
Hat sich ausgemixt.
Kassania kannst du mitnehmen? Danke. Und ist da viel los? Ja? Okay, da ist auch viel los.
Wir beziehen von denen dann Kartoffeln seit über drei Jahren jetzt.
Moin, hi.
Natürlich immer abgedeckt. Wenn die Licht kriegen, dann fangen die an zu peilen.
Es lässt sich so, weil es ist sehr feuer.
Wenn auf einmal die Kartoffel eine Wurzel hat, ist es nicht so gut.
Dass die Kartoffeln auch richtig abgedeckt sind, dass die keine Wurzel rausbekommen oder sowas.
Bei anderen Händlern hat es das nicht so erfahren.
Deswegen freue ich mich, so zu sehen. Wirklich. Top.
Ich schmeiß den drauf. Super.
Den Rest kriegst du morgen, übermorgen, wenn du dann die Bestellung durchgibst.
Ordentlicher Sack Kartoffel.
Der ist ein bisschen länger geworden, weil er jetzt während zwischen 10 Uhr und 18 Uhr nicht mit dem Auto fahren darf.
Der ist aber gut beschäftigt, der muss sich um alles Mögliche kümmern.
Vom Einkaufen bis zum Einspringen, beim Verkaufen helfen, zwischendurch Zeug reparieren.
Guck mal, der Beitrag ist schon fast acht Minuten, er hat die ganze Zeit gearbeitet.
Nicht so wie diese komische Excel-schubsende Marketing-Frau da, die wir mal hatten in dem Beitrag.
Den ganzen Tag nur irgendwas im Excel eingetragen hat.
So eine lange Wechsel-Ebene, aber das muss ja, das muss getan werden.
Jetzt mache ich einen kleinen Pause.
Da wiegt schon ein bisschen was.
Hab ich dann wieder.
Das ist alles.
Prasanthi, ich habe ein paar Pommes gekauft.
Das war nicht sehr einfach.
Wir haben heute einen Umsatz mit Trinkgeld 346,55 Euro und Trinkgeld ist 9,55 Euro.
Somit haben wir einen Umsatz von 337 Euro und ich bin eigentlich sehr zufrieden damit.
Ich hatte natürlich ein bisschen mehr erwartet.
Mittags läuft sehr gut.
Es muss dann auch Abend laufen.
Aber das ist glaube ich bei allen diesen Läden so, dass mittags halt ein riesen Andrang ist.
Das sehe ich bei den Restaurants ja in Frankfurt auch.
Da ist mittags immer, da stehen sich die Leute die Beine in den Bauch.
Und ab 13 Uhr ist dann tote Hose.
In den nächsten Tagen wird mehr Umsatz generiert.
Ich glaube es liegt daran nur, dass der Laden ganz neu ist und nicht viele über uns dann wissen.
Für den alten Laden hatte ich einen Umsatz von 800 Euro erwartet. Wir haben 876 Euro kassiert und somit bin ich eigentlich sehr, sehr happy.
Das Wetter war nicht gut, also wetterabhängig ist unser Laden sehr und das war deswegen ein krasser Umsatz. 870 Euro kann man nicht beschweren.
Ich habe im Jahr 2024 einen Umsatz von 230.000 Euro gemacht.
Damit bleibt mir ein Gewinn vor Store in der Höhe von 54.400 Euro übrig.
Das wären dann 3.600 Euro, die ich mir zur Verfügung stelle.
Mein größtes Ziel für SuperCompere wäre dann, dass wir in ein Franchise-System gehen.
Und somit haben wir dann mehrere...
Da startet jetzt der Business-Crime.
Das wäre mein Ziel.
Geld spielt ja eine große Rolle für jeden, für mich genauso.
Mir ist auch wichtig, dass es so wie weiter auch acht bis zehn Leute hier Arbeit geben kann,
meine Eltern ein gutes Leben anbieten kann.
Cricket ist dann ein Ausgleich für mich in meinem Leben zwischen Arbeit, Leben und Freizeit.
Das ist mein Baby.
Ich bin Abteilungsleiter, ich bin der Mannschaftskapitän und auch Trainer.
Versuch mit beiden Händen, okay?
Cricket ist meine zweite Liebe.
So geil ist es.
Meine Verlobte ist natürlich meine erste Liebe.
Chat, ich checkte das auch nicht. Keine Ahnung, was Sie da treiben.
Was ich anders sagen würde, freut sich das nicht.
Beim Cricket Training bin ich nicht der Ladenbesitzer, ich bin nicht der Chef, sondern ich bin einfach mal ein Mensch, der Cricket spielen möchte.
Das ist auch eine Verbindung zwischen mir, zwischen Deutschland und Nepal, weil Cricket gibt mir ein Heimatsgefühl.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, die hauen sich eine Ofenkartoffel abends rein.
Ich unterstütze meine Eltern sehr viel.
In dem ist dann ein paar Monate Geld nach Nepal gezahlt oder ihre ganze Ausgabe, was
sie dann haben, auch bezahlen.
Ich überweise meinen Eltern fast jeden zweiten bis dritten Monat 1.000 Euro.
Und das ist dann eigentlich sehr viel Geld in Nepal.
Für uns ist die Familienzeit ganz, ganz wichtig und die verbringen wir immer zusammen.
Ich bin stolz, dass ich hier ein gutes Leben für mich aufgebaut habe.
Ich sehe das nicht rein als Geldmacher.
Ich sehe auch soziale Aspekte, zum Beispiel auch, wo ich dann meine Angestellte habe,
wo ich denen dann auch mit Selbstunterstützung.
Es ist nicht ein großer Gewinn oder sowas, aber ich würde das jeden Tag auswählen und somit lohnt sich das.
Er hat wirklich von morgens bis abends durchgeschafft.
Das ist bestimmt anstrengend.
Toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss.
Anstrengend.
Jetzt weiß ich wieder,
welche bescheuerten Shorts empfohlen kriege auf YouTube.
Meine Güte.
Moin, Salix.
Ich hab Hunger.
Wisst ihr, dass ich jetzt immer viel früher Hunger kriege?
Weil ich geh bei mir auf der Arbeit.
Ich geh ja oft nach Frankfurt aktuell gerade.
Und ich geh immer um 11.30 Uhr schon in die Kantine,
weil da nicht viel los ist.
Und seitdem ich das mache,
hab ich jetzt immer 11.30 Uhr schon Hunger.
Aber ich sollte noch mal mindestens, also 40 Minuten sollte ich schon noch warten.
Was es heute gibt? Nein, es gibt keine Nudeln mit Lachs, es gibt auch keine Bolognese.
Es gibt Nudeln mit Currysoße dabei.
Was ist mit dem Homeoffice-Cry passiert?
Der Homeoffice-Cry, also ich mache das freiwillig, ja.
Also ich werde nicht gezwungen nach Frankfurt zu fahren, muss ich gleich sagen.
Ich lenke mich gerade ein bisschen ab.
auf der Arbeit.
Mein Problem,
die ich so hab.
Und mir ist aufgefallen,
dass es, also gerade seitdem ich da wieder öfters
in Frankfurt bin,
wie viel Essen es bei uns
auf der Arbeit gibt, ey.
Wir haben ja nicht nur eine Kantine,
es gibt auch total viel Automaten und sowas
und es ist echt günstig.
Bei uns stehen so Snack-Automaten rum.
Richtig Pepo-Fett-Time.
Da stehen Snack-Automaten rum.
Und da gibt es Ritter Sport drin.
Und die Ritter Sport kostet nur 1,20.
Ich glaube, was kosten die im Laden mittlerweile?
2 Euro?
Was kostet...
Ich guck mal bei Amazon.
Was kostet mittlerweile eine Ritter Sport?
Hallo?
Äh, was ist das?
24 und wie viel sind das?
Wie viel sind das?
13 mal.
Okay, 24 durch 13.
1,84.
Siehste?
Da kann ich mit 1,20, kann man sich ja wirklich nicht beschweren.
Und an einem Kiosk kostet es bestimmt 2 Euro.
Ja.
Steht da?
Echt, stand das da, wie viel ein Einzelner kostet?
Wirklich?
Ah.
Ja, hab ich nicht gesehen.
Aber da haben wir doch richtig gerechnet.
Ja.
Und das ist das Problem, ich fress dann immer
noch ne Rittersport,
weil ich mir denke, ey, für 1,20
kannst du nix falsch machen.
Aber ich hab trotzdem nicht zugenommen.
Also Bewegung,
Bewegung regelt anscheinend.
aber aufstehen aufstehen bisschen beine ausschütteln du gehst 7000 schritte am
tag ich mag ich habe meine fitness nur nicht waren
kein bock mich da die ganze zeit zu kontrollieren
das stimmt wenn man in frankfurt es gibt man mehr geld aus
holst du dir einen Adventskalender?
Nee, ich hab mal kurz überlegt,
weil ich gesehen hab, der
Vera Weihnachtskalender war im Angebot.
Aber ich hab da
überhaupt keinen Anwendungs
Zweck für.
Total unsinnig. Ich hol mir
keinen Weihnachtskalender.
Sarix, holst du dir einen Weihnachtskalender?
Also ich hab wie gesagt, ich hab kurz
überlegt aber wozu macht keinen sinn
was das sagt leute ich habe gerade eine nachricht gekriegt auf meinem
arbeitshandy was ist da los
sekunde ist das hier
alter ist es sonntag
Kannst du bitte folgende Tasks ausführen?
Start...
Was? Alter, es ist Sonntag. The fuck?
Ich führe jetzt keine Tasks aus.
PTF?
Nee, ich lege...
Wisst ihr... Leute, Trick 17.
Trick 17.
Ihr dürft die Teams-Messages nur auf dem Startbildschirm lesen, ihr dürft die nicht aufmachen, weil sobald ihr die aufmacht, sieht man gelesen.
Wenn ihr die nur auf dem Startbildschirm anguckt, sehen die nicht als gelesen aus.
Sieht man die nicht als gelesen.
Spy-Words sind aber auch so okay.
Also ich vermute mal
Das wurde nicht geschrieben
Wirklich mit der Erwartung
Dass ich das heute mache
Ich gehe davon aus
Die haben irgendwelche
Irgendwelche Wartungsarbeiten
Gerade am Wochenende
Und haben das schon mal geschrieben
Für Montag
Aber ich habe mich halt gewundert
Weil das Handy gerade vibriert hat
Montag bin ich eh nicht da
Also für Dienstag dann
Die Streams snipen mich bestimmt
Genau
Ich werde stream sniped.
Das wird's sein.
Genau, die stream snipen mich in seiner...
Max, du hast die Nachricht doch genau gesehen.
Cute Fetch. Was ist das?
Tiny Colored Fetch Script.
Cute Little Animals.
Ah.
Bunny Fetch.
Braucht man nicht wirklich.
Written in?
Written in shell.
Wo ist das Source Code?
Ich seh hier Kütfetsch.
Okay, das ist ein Bash.
Gleich steht im Chat was
So, mal gucken, ob es hier Package-Updates gibt
Das ist schon immerhin 40 Minuten her
Wo war der letzte Package-Update?
Und, wie jetzt?
Arch Linux, ich bin enttäuscht
Das ist mir nicht mal Bleeding Edge genug
Mein System ist 40 Minuten alt
Das geht aber nicht
I lost my job to AI
Okay, das Video mag nicht
So, I lost my job
Das können wir uns dann angucken.
Glasfaser, Netzwerkverkabelung.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Software-Updates, Deletes, Everything, All in 10 Days.
Schauen wir mal.
Ah, das habe ich gelesen.
Das habe ich gelesen.
Das war in irgendeiner japanischen Uni.
Kann das sein?
Ach ne.
King College London war das?
Ne doch hier, Kyoto University
Genau
Das habe ich gelesen
Bei, ich glaube auf Reddit irgendwo
Irgendein Skript hat Files gelöscht
Auf dem Fileserver, ja
wartet mal kurz olio mixer ist eigentlich so richtig
viel zu wenig tabs ja das ist glaube ich das problem deswegen leckt man mein system auch
das skaliert mit der anzahl der geöffneten tabs
Ich verstehe dich nicht.
Das haben wir auf der alten Arbeit auch mal ausprobiert.
Lustre FS.
Das kommt mir noch bekannt vor.
Ja, wir hatten es dann auch nicht im Einsatz.
Kann mich nur noch dunkel dran erinnern, aber der Name kam mir bekannt vor.
Moin Ritz-Koll!
log files lying around forever which is why most systems have a way to rotate logs old logs can be
compressed archived and eventually deleted gibt es auch eine story von der arbeit zu logs ey manchmal
komme ich mir echt also im business enterprise umfeld kommt man sich echt teilweise bescheuert
vor ne gab eine monitoring meldung ein klassiker schlechthin filesystem läuft voll reingeguckt aha
da liegen irgendwelche Anwendungslogs.
Allerdings nicht nur irgendwelche Anwendungslogs,
sondern Binary-Anwendungslogs.
Ich habe da mal kurz Strings drauf gemacht
und habe festgestellt,
da stehen da tatsächlich irgendwelche Sachen drin.
Okay, vielleicht sollte ich mir die besser nicht angucken.
Vielleicht ist das was, was ich eigentlich gar nicht sehen darf.
Also wieder zugemacht.
Festgestellt, da liegen Dateien seit 2017 oder so.
Liegen da irgendwelche Binary-Logfiles rum.
die sich jetzt aufsummiert haben.
Wir reden hier über Logfiles von, das ist nicht viel,
ich glaube 5 Gigabyte oder so, nicht wirklich viel.
Also das ist ganz langsam gewachsen über die Zeit.
So, und da hatten wir unser letztes,
wir haben ja ab und zu alle 14 Tage zu diesem Service
so eine Besprechung, wo dann die Leute dabei sind,
die das benutzen oder ein paar von denen das benutzen,
die die Anwendung darauf verantworten
und wir halt für die Infrastruktur unten drunter.
und haben das angesprochen.
Die meinten nur, ja, wir fragen mal nach
bei den Anwendungsverantwortlichen,
ob wir das löschen können.
Ich habe auch gemeint, also uns wird nichts anderes übrig bleiben,
als das zu löschen oder irgendwie wegzuschreiben,
weil bald ist die Platte voll, dann passiert da gar nichts mehr.
Ja, okay.
Nächstes Anwendungsmeeting 14 Tage später.
Ja, die haben sich bis jetzt noch nicht geäußert.
Ja gut, jetzt sind aber, wir sind schon bei 4,5 Gigabyte von 5.
Ja, okay, wir fragen nochmal nach.
Nächstes Anwendungsmeeting.
Wie sieht es jetzt eigentlich mit den Logs aus?
Wir müssen da so langsam mal was rechnen.
Wir sind jetzt bei 4,8 Gigabyte von 5.
Wie sieht es denn aus?
Ja, die können sich nicht dazu durchringen,
zu sagen, dass wir was löschen dürfen.
Da habe ich mir auch so gedacht, weißt du was?
Das ist kein Datenbankfall.
Das war einfach irgendwelche Logs mit uraltes Zeug,
was keiner mehr braucht.
Ich habe mir gedacht, weißt du was?
Wenn es so weitergeht, löscht es jetzt einfach mal was
und das merkt bestimmt keiner.
Aber nee, mach sie nicht. Lass sie bleiben.
Und irgendwann, als das wirklich so ganz kurz vor knapp war,
ich hab dann auch mal gepostet, Leute, in zwei Tagen oder so ist voll,
dann kack das ab.
Dann haben sie mir ein Ticket aufgemacht,
ja, bitte alles löschen seit 2023.
Ursprünglicher Plan war, wir machen da nämlich einen Rotate rein,
aber da konnten sie sich nicht dazu durchringen, mir zu sagen,
in welchem Intervall das rotatet werden soll.
Und jetzt ist der Plan, jetzt ist der Plan, wir löschen es, also war der Plan, wir löschen es einmalig und dann hoffen wir, dass mit dem Server-Neuaufbau und der neuen Version es nicht mehr so viele Logs gibt.
Das ist, äh, weiß ich nicht, wie man auf die Idee kommt, aber, also unser Plan ist eigentlich Prage, Prage ist der Plan. Der Plan ist einfach nur Prage, in der Hoffnung, dann wird das schon, wird schon wieder besser.
Es wird jetzt natürlich auch zwei, drei Jahre halten,
selbst wenn der Server nicht neu aufgebaut wird,
weil es wächst nur total, also richtig total langsam, die Logs.
Aber das ist halt wirklich typisches Business Enterprise Gedöns.
Was bedeutet Prager?
Prager ist ein Emote.
Das ist das Emote hier, Prager.
Das ist Pepe, der am Beten ist.
Prager.
Okay, weiter.
Warte mal, Chat, ich muss gerade mal was lesen.
Chat und Max, Container Registry gesucht für Lokalhost Artifactory.
Ich dachte Artifactory ist kostenlos.
Kostet das Geld?
Wir haben nämlich auf der Arbeit auch Artifactory.
Also, das muss ich jetzt anders sagen.
Also wir bezahlen dafür Geld, das weiß ich.
Aber ich dachte, das kann man so benutzen,
wenn man das nicht businessmäßig benutzt.
Kostet das Geld?
Dachte eigentlich für private Nutzung,
das ist kostenlos.
Na gut.
Container Registry gibt es einige.
Es gibt Haber zum Beispiel.
Mittlerweile hat sogar GitLab.
GitLab hat glaube ich mittlerweile sogar eine Container Registry eingebaut.
Und sogar Gitea hat oder Giti oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht, hat eine Container Registry.
Gitea Container Registry.
Die haben auch eine eingebaut.
Also es gibt ein paar Alternativen. Also wenn du wirklich nur was für Container suchst. Artifactory kann ja noch viel mehr. Artifactory kann beispielsweise auch Container Registries proxien. Das ist ganz furchtbar weird, Champ. Irgendjemand hat mal entschieden, man darf nicht mehr direkt auf Docker Hub zugreifen.
Weil Docker Hub ist ja
potenziell
wie heißt das hier?
Supplychain-Attackte-Images
und hast du nicht gesehen. Also man darf nicht mehr direkt
auf Docker Hub zugreifen.
Hat einer bei uns auf der Arbeit entschieden.
Dann haben sie allerdings festgestellt, ja wir brauchen
aber Docker-Images.
Und jetzt wird das geproxied über Artifactory.
Was halt überhaupt nichts ändert da dran.
Weil es ist jetzt
nicht etwa so, als wären die Images dadurch sicher,
dass sie geproxied werden.
Aber wir können jetzt sagen, richtlinienmäßig, wir greifen nicht mehr direkt auf Docker Hub zu.
Es macht zwar überhaupt keinen Unterschied, aber wir greifen nicht mehr direkt auf Docker Hub zu.
Das ist dann besser.
Der Frasier. Wir wollten tatsächlich letztes Jahr oder so ein Video aufnehmen, haben es aber nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Ja, der casht das wahrscheinlich dazwischen, ja.
mag sein, also bisher konnte ich alle Images pullen
ne, ne
ich hab vorhin, ich hab
ne, nicht vorhin, ich hab letztens irgendwas total
obskures gepullt
äh, Bitcoin
in einem Bitcoin, ähm
Node, habe ich, Image habe ich gepullt
das hat garantiert keiner vorher freigegeben
So, gucken wir jetzt erstmal das Video fertig.
Ja, normalerweise.
Sag mal, ist die Voice nicht AI-generiert, oder? Hört sich aber ein bisschen AI-generiert an.
wie C, Go und Rust, die alle bekannt sind für ihre Fasten.
Aber Maschinencode ist platformabhängig.
Also muss ein C-Programm, das auf Windows kompiliert wird, für Linux wiedergekompiliert werden.
Aber es gibt auch ein Zwischenverhältnis.
Wir können den menschlichen lesbaren Code
für Computerprogramme effizienter machen, aber ohne ihn so effizient zu machen,
dass der Code nur auf dem System, auf dem er kompiliert wird, ausgerüstet werden kann.
Dies nennt man Bytecode.
In Java ist dein Ursprungscode zuerst kompiliert
und dann in ein JAR-File archiviert.
In .NET ist es ja auch so, außer mit AOT.
Das ist die komplette Applikation, die in ein convenience bytecode Package gewechselt wird.
Dann kann man das JAR-File mit einem speziellen Programm nennen,
das die Java Virtual Machine ist.
Eine Virtual Machine, die nur weiß, wie man Java bytecode interpretiert.
Der Vorteil hier ist, dass die JVM
keine Systeme oder Hardware-Vergleiche abstrackt.
So as long as you install it once, you can run any and all Java bytecode.
Of the same major version of course.
Every programming language falls into these two categories, interpreted or compiled.
But the thing being interpreted at runtime is usually bytecode,
or some other intermediary structure produced prior to execution.
Bash is unique in that it incrementally parses and executes lines of the source code during runtime.
It does this just like any other process reads a file.
The Bash-Prozess will create a pointer called the FileDescriptor aimed at the kernel file table entry,
which contains metadata of the open file, such as the current read location called the file offset,
Was hat das jetzt genau mit dem Löschen der Log-Files zu tun?
Another pointer to the inode table.
Inodes basically represent the file itself, containing metadata such as ownership, timestamps,
and pointers to where the file's data blocks are stored on disk.
Ah!
Okay, jetzt verstehe ich den Zusammenhang.
Wir haben das Bash-Skript gestartet und dann wurde das Bash-Skript quasi unter der Haube irgendwie geändert.
Wenn wir den neuen Script mit dem neuen Script verändern wollen, gibt es zwei offensichtliche Optionen.
Man kann entweder MVMove oder CP Copy den neuen Script, um den neuen Script zu verändern.
In beiden Fällen endet man mit dem neuen Script, der zu geupdatetem Input bezieht,
aber einer von ihnen macht einen In-Place-Overwrite, während der andere einen Atom-Swap verwendet.
Welcher schafft welchen? Wenn du die Antwort dazu kennst, bist du ein verpflichteter Unix-Meister.
Aber bevor ich die Antwort erkämpfe, was genau ist ein Atom-Swap?
Das Wort Atom kommt aus dem griechischen Wort Atomos, was Indivisible bedeutet.
Damals konnte man Atome nicht teilen, also konnten sie keinen Partial-Stand haben.
Deshalb bedeutet es, dass ein Veränderung atomisch sein kann, ohne dass jemand einen Partial-Stand sieht.
Wenn ich neue Skripte in den aktuellen Skripte wechsle,
macht Linux einfach den aktuellen Skript-Direktoren-Entrieb an den neuen Skript-Eyenode.
Da es nur einen Schritt gibt, gibt es keinen Partial-Stand.
Wenn man die Syscalls von MV beobachtet, sieht man, dass es nur eine Einzelrename-Operation ist.
Weiterhin können Prozesse, die das File vor dem Swap eröffnen, den alten Inode immer noch nutzen.
Hier ist es in Aktion.
Mit ls-i können wir die Inoden-Nummern von beiden Filen sehen.
Nach dem Run MV hat das aktuelle Skript die geupdateten Inodes, aber schaut euch das Inode an.
Es wurde gezwappt zu dem Inode-Nummer von New Script.
On the other hand, if I copy new script to current script, the current script's inode is unchanged.
It performed an in-place modification of its existing inode.
As you can see from the syscalls used in CP, it is not a single step.
Was ist ein inode? Das ist Filesystem-Info über die Datei, die du...
Weiß ich nicht, was ist ein inode?
Das ist irgendein Eintrag im Filesystem
über den gespeicherten Content.
Also sowas wie
letzter Zugriffs
Zeit. Ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie man das genau beschreiben soll.
Passt mal auf.
So als Wikipedia.
Ja.
Ein iNode ist die grundlegende
Datenstrukturverwaltung von Dateisystemen
in Unix ADM Betriebssystem
Also
das einzige, wo ich ein bisschen was
mit iNodes mal zu tun hatte ist
als wir ganz viele kleine Dateien erstellt haben
da gingen irgendwann
die iNodes aus
bevor der Speicher voll war
ansonsten kein Schimmer
was da
wie das genau ist, das ist
ganz low-level
File-System-Zeug.
Das sind nicht nur File-System-Metadaten,
da sind auch die Dateien
gespeichert.
Ich hab kein, keine Ahnung, kann ich nicht genau
erklären.
kann in einem teils geschriebenen Zustand eingeführt werden, wenn man mit dem Zeitpunkt
nicht glücklich ist.
Außerdem, auch wenn nichts das teils geschriebenen File eingeführt hat, weil es sich verändert
hat, haben die existierenden Prozesse, die das File geöffnet haben, nun den neuen Inhalt
beobachtet.
BASH zum Beispiel wird die neue File von der aktuellen Position seines File-Pointers
weiter lesen, die bereits geparsierte Teile des alten Files, die in der Erinnerung gehalten
werden, mit dem was es lesen will.
Das wird die meiste Zeit krasse, da der Offset nicht unbedingt sauber zwischen den Befehlen
Aber wenn die Übertragung zwischen dem alten und neuen Skripte die richtige Syntaxe erhält,
und du wirklich unfreundlich wirst, kann etwas ziemlich verrücktes passieren.
Schauen wir uns einen Cleanup-Skript an, der ähnlich wie HP verwendet werden könnte.
Dieser Skript findet einfach alle File in der Log-Direktorie, die über 10 Tage alt sind,
und deliziert sie.
Jetzt will HP den Skript verbessern.
alles unterhalb von
Large Null.
AP hat wohl
alle Daten der Kyoto University
oder alle Daten in diesem Cluster
von der Kyoto University gelöscht.
Aus Versehen.
Ja, und Logdir ist jetzt leer, weil das hier oben nie ausgeführt wurde.
Ja, ist layout.
Tja.
Dann hoffen wir mal, dass sie ein Backup haben, hä?
77 Terabyte?
work hours. But if we look closer at the letter, HP actually calls the script a Baku-Apu-Sukuri-Puto,
or backup script, meaning that it's probable the script was also doing a bunch of other backup
stuff and the log deletion was just a little cherry on top of the much larger job that took
a while. In this case, the chance of the overwrite race condition increases dramatically.
Fortunately, the Baku-Apu-Skripto was not completely useless, as 49 terabytes of the
deleted data was backed up, so only 28 TB were lost, causing a mere 4 departments to
permanently lose everything.
HP quickly came in and apologized, taking 100% responsibility for the incident and provided
die Kompensation in Ordnung mit den Wünschen der verursachten User.
Also ist es klar, dass das Problem nie geschehen würde, wenn die Strip-Update mit einem Methoden
geplägt wurde, der die i-Node nicht in den Platz schafft, wie MV.
Wenn du über das Begeben des Kopierens preferierst, gibt es eine CP-Flagge, die sich nennt
Remove Destination, die die alte i-Node verlinkt, damit die existierenden Prozesse von ihr weiter
lesen können und eine neue i-Node für den neuen File-Content errichten.
However, please note that neither of these are fully atomic across different file systems.
So if you want something that's absolutely safe, you can always write the new script to a temporary file in the same file system or folder and then do the rename.
Ja, gucken wir.
On the bash side, there are various flags you can set, such as the u-flag, which causes the program to error out when there are unset variables, rather than interpreting them as empty strings.
Aber dass sie keine Backups haben, ist auch geil. Die waren ja beauftragt, damit Backups zu machen.
Alternativ können Sie versuchen, eine sicherere Sprache zu benutzen, wie Python oder Microsoft.
Am Ende steht die Kyoto-Universität noch als die Nummer 1 Universität in Kyoto und schlägt sich für den Gold-Metal an der internationalen Synthetischen Biologie-Kompetition, die in ein paar Tagen das letzte Beurteilen hat.
Besten Glückwunsch an sie und erinnere sich immer...
Jetzt aber Updates, hä?
Immer noch nicht.
Meine Güte.
So, Leute, ich geh jetzt was futtern.
Ich hab Hunger.
Oh, mir tut der Hintern weh vom Sitzen.
Alles klar.
Nee, keine Nudeln mit Lachs.
Nee, ist zu kalt.
Ich könnte mich hier auf meinen
Kicker hocken.
Aber, nee.
Heute mache ich gar nichts.
Heute sitze ich vorm Computer und fresse.
So wie das sein muss sonntags.
Heute gibt es Nudeln mit Curry-Soße.
Es war gestern auch arschkalt.
Minus 6 Grad.
Ich habe heute noch gar nicht geguckt.
Mal kurz gucken, wie kalt ist es denn heute?
Muss mal Home Assistant aufmachen.
Es ist minus 2,11.
Hast du das neue Katzenbild gesehen?
Nee.
Guck mal.
Das ist essentiell jetzt.
Aus besteht die Currysoße?
Keine Ahnung, das ist so fertige Currysoße halt.
Keine Ahnung, aus was die besteht.
Wahrscheinlich Sahne?
Currypulver?
Wo ist denn hier mein...
Cute...
Cute Chat muss ich mit Katzenbild gucken, gell?
warum postest du den Poppes von deiner Katze
Torz
so Leute
bis dann, macht's gut, see you